Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 is here
and once again Groot has stolen the show
this time as a pint-sized sapling of his
former self after the first film it's
easy to assume you might know everything
there is to know about this talking tree
but groot's Roots Run Deep And there are
more than a few buried secrets fans
might not know about Groot and his many
forms I speak for the trees Vin Diesel
the voice of Groot is getting a nice
payday just to say the same three words
over and over I am cruel but the part of
the skill involved is saying those three
words with emotion
[Music]
one of the film's running themes is that
Groot is actually having a complex
conversation with those who can
understand him like rocket so where does
that leave diesel
he's confirmed that he actually works
from a secret script with real dialogue
which means everything that Groot utters
actually has a very literal meaning
behind it you just need to be diesel
writer director James Gunn or a space
raccoon in order to figure it out and
while Vin Diesel has built a career out
of playing badasses it caught some by
surprise when he played the voice of a
CGI tree and later the even higher voice
of a tinier version of that tree even
more surprising baby groot's voice is
almost completely Diesel with very
little voice modulation
in an interview with Entertainment
Tonight diesel revealed that he'd been
practicing copying the voices of cartoon
characters from a very young age diesel
just happens to be right at home doing
silly voices on command so he had no
trouble voicing Baby Groot naturally
say what Groot is mostly known for his
three magic words I am Groot but during
his early comic appearances Groot was
much more talkative so what happened
according to one possible Theory
presented by Marvel groot's race all
have a weirdly specific condition their
larynx hardens as they get older leaving
them only capable of emitting a handful
of words while Baby Groot retains his
tiny vocal vocabulary in the sequel
Comics law says that he might have been
able to say a lot more he's a real life
hero while it wasn't the original intent
behind Groot he's a pretty logical
mascot for ecological causes the guys
are freaking tree after all so it turns
out Disney agrees under Disney's
guidance YouTuber D-Trix created a dance
move inspired by a dancing baby Groot
toy
[Music]
after each Marvel fan who used the
hashtag Groot dance form between April
18th and May 5th or simply liked or
shared the original video Disney donated
one dollar to The Nature Conservancy up
to 250 000 baby grew didn't just help
save the Galaxy his dance moves are
helping save planet Earth 2. new Twist
on Old routes as a twig sized type baby
groot's personality has changed from his
first film appearance he's now a baby in
more than just name the movie implies
that his intelligence and personality
revolve around his relative age
something which is made explicit with
groot's appearance as a surly teenager
during a mid-credit scene however this
idea of goods changing personality isn't
from the comics where he's had to regrow
a number of times as far as Comics are
concerned group can grow back from even
a tiny sliver and and when he does he
still has all of his adult groot's
memories so he doesn't go through any
prolonged relearning face and even if he
did it would probably be moot the Groot
of the comics usually grows much faster
than the movie Groot who's taken a bit
of time to go from potted plant to
toddler tree roots of aggression one of
the interesting side effects of Groot
being regrown is that the younger
version seems more aggressive than his
former Elder self sure Groot could fight
when he had to but baby Groot takes the
battle with Zeal but is it really that
much of a surprise in his earliest
Comics appearances Groot was a different
kind of monster and Tall broad
articulate and evil he tried to take
over Earth and he posed just as much of
a threat as any Marvel villain but as he
got older he mellowed out and became a
hero baby groots unexpectedly violent
mood swings may be just because he's in
his tree equivalent of the terrible twos
but they also could be from James Gunn
channeling groot's pulpy Origins
whatever the reason the tiny tree
practically stole the show and in a
movie with this many weirdos that's
saying something
oh wow I know it almost hit me
there's no super villain quite like
Thanos the Mad Titan he's been a menace
to the Marvel Universe since 1973 when
he made his debut in Iron Man number 55
and few villains have proven as
formidable despite his long history in
Marvel Comics Thanos has never been as
high profile as he is now you probably
already know that he's a nihilist Cosmic
warlord who set on assembling The
Infinity Gauntlet allowing him to wipe
out Life as We Know It set that aside
though and you'll find a ton of
fascinating components to the character
that are slightly lesser known this is
the Untold Truth of Thanos tell me his
name again
aesthetic inspiration
Thanos is far from the most unique
Creation in the history of comics
created by writer and artist Jim Starlin
Thanos shares many similarities with
characters created by another Comics
luminary Jack Kirby specifically Kirby's
work on DC's New Gods series Starlin
initially based Thanos on the new God's
character Metron a genius Celestial
Observer to the events of the DC
Universe many have thought thanos's
inspiration to be the DC character
Darkseid but according to Starland that
wasn't initially the case speaking in a
1998 interview with comic book artist
Starlin said you'd think that Thanos was
inspired by Darkseid but that was not
the case when I showed up in my first
Thanos drawings if he looked like
anybody it was Metron Roy took one look
at the guy in the Metron like chair and
said beef him up if you're gonna steal
one of the new Gods at least rip off
Darkseid the really good one fortunately
the resemblance is only skin deep the
two characters have vastly different
motivations and levels of empathy and
Thanos has fleetingly fought alongside
Heroes before we think it's safe to say
that's not really dark side style I
grabbed you a quick death
foreign
this may come as a shock from the looks
of him but Thanos descends from a race
of aliens that actually look more or
less human Thanos is a carrier of the
Deviant Gene sort of the equivalent of a
mutant in his race his mother father and
the rest of his family are members of a
super-powered alien race called the
eternals living on Titan one of Saturn's
moons they look human and when his
mother suisan became pregnant they
expected him to look the same when
Thanos was born however one look at him
sent all expectations out the window
including the name his mother intended
to give him before she realized Thanos
was a deviant his mother intended to
name him Dion however when her child was
born she was horrified by his mutation
and upon looking into his eyes she
realized he was the harbinger of the
universe's ultimate destruction and made
a huge mistake there's a lot more
messing up this mother-son relationship
than just unfulfilled expectations and a
gross chin suisan tried to execute
Thanos as a child and Thanos
successfully returned the favor later in
life their complex tumultuous
relationship began with a simple name
change the shorthand is the the
butterfly effect a butterfly could flap
his wings and Peking and Central Park
you get rain instead of essential
collecting the gems the Marvel Cinematic
Universe spent more than 10 years
building up thanos's search for the
powerful six Infinity Stones or gems as
they used to be known but it only took
him two comic books to accomplish a goal
that's taken a decade to get done on
screen with the Mad Titan snatching up
the gems one by one in a 1990 comic
called the Thanos Quest the two-part
story saw Thanos traveling the universe
and liberating the six gems from their
owners and they were all in very
different hands compared to their
cinematic counterparts first Thanos
attacked the imprisoned in-betweener
stealing the green soul gem from his
head next he liberated the red Power gym
from the champion in a physical contest
installed the time gym from The Gardener
and ageless Elder of the universe the
yellow reality gym he pilferred from The
Collector who you may remember from
Guardians of the Galaxy the purple space
gym was taken from the runner and the
blue mine gym was nabbed from the Grand
Master yes that Grand Master from Thor
Ragnarok
[Music]
all of these foes fell with a surprising
quickness when challenged clearing the
way for Thanos to assume the powers of a
God in the Titanic 1991 event series The
Infinity Gauntlet
courting death
many of thanos's stories Chronicle the
Titans obsessive passion for the living
personification of death it's a
relationship that was foreshadowed by
his very name Jim Starlin originally
came up with the character of Thanos
while taking a college psychology class
he based thanos's personality off of the
Freudian concept of the death Drive in
other words the psychological impulse to
end one's own existence his name is
reminiscent of Thanatos the Greek
mythological figure who was said to
represent death in Marvel Comics Canon
death is an actual person a skeletal
female entity who is sometimes referred
to as lady or mistress death while
Thanos is completely in love with her
death often refuses to entertain his
advances or even acknowledge his
existence leading Thanos to lash out and
seek attention through his Universe
destroying scheme while death does
eventually entertain a romance with
Thanos to say it's complicated would be
putting it lightly it certainly wasn't
worth all of the destruction in the end
thanos's battle against the universe's
strongest Heroes was all done for the
sake of impressing a girl she's not even
all that good looking
My Own Worst Enemy all of thanos's
Bluster covers up a lot of insecurity as
both The Infinity Gauntlet and the
character's solo outings have shown
Thanos is surprisingly something of a
self-defeating Sad Sack
on the surface his goals would seem to
be the same as any other super villain
world domination and destruction however
thanos's motivations transcend typical
villainy he believes in Oblivion like a
religion in all but worship's death
itself in his own Twisted way he
believes he's doing the right thing the
universe is Unworthy of existence
therefore it falls on him to give it
what it deserves the nihilism doesn't
stop with his view towards all other
life it applies to him as well not even
Thanos is worthy this is why Thanos
despite his power never manages to stay
on top for too long it's firmly
established in Infinity Gauntlet that he
ultimately fails because he allows
himself to he will always subconsciously
leave a hole in his plans that the
heroes can exploit to bring about his
defeat as much as he believes that the
Universe deserves to die he doesn't
believe himself worthy of the task at
hand for such a formidable otherworldly
figure that's a pretty human flaw
fanocide amalgam Comics is a pretty
interesting corner of comics lore a
joint venture between Marvel and DC it
featured characters that were you
guessed it amalgamations of Marvel and
DC characters the world of amalgam is
populated by Heroes like Bruce Wayne
agent of shield and Doctor Strange fade
and it didn't stop with Heroes the
universe also featured amalgamations of
villains from both Publishers and you
can probably guess who Thanos was paired
with Thanos and Darkseid combine to form
thanoside like Darkseid thanoside rules
the planet of apocalypse and like Thanos
he has an ambition to wipe out the
universe in the events that led to their
combining in the amalgam Universe
Darkseid actually insulted Thanos
calling Thanos just a pale imitation of
him a funny nod to thanos's Origins
amalgam's Comics weren't exactly
Classics but they were a whole lot of
fun
kicking it with the boys
one might reasonably assume the Marvel
Universe only had room for one
nihilistic death Titan that would be
incorrect one of the more interesting
corners of thanos's History involves a
personal Army of clones he made of
himself these clones are known as the
fanocyte and are formed by Thanos
splicing his DNA with that of other
Marvel heroes and villains there's Omega
a cross between Thanos and Galactus for
instance Thanos creates the thanocyte to
test the abilities of enemies and allies
alike eventually he considers them
failures and abandons them shockingly
the Thanos side don't take this
portrayal particularly well they band
together and being an army of Thanos
clones attempt to bring about the
ultimate end of the universe luckily
they fail given thanos's General
Tendencies an army of Thanos clones
ending up trying to destroy the
universes in any kind of surprise
my brother the lover no matter how many
times he impressively destroys the
universe or lies himself with the good
guys Thanos will never be as loved as
his brother Star Fox no not that Star
Fox the Star Fox of the Marvel Universe
also called Eros is a Carefree
easy-going flirt his Charming
personality is only Amplified by his
superpowers which include a sort of
pheromone effect he can make people
within 25 feet of him feel Joy
effectively drawing them to him when
cranked up it can provoke romantic
feelings he's basically a sentient
Marvin Gaye record which is pretty tough
to compete with when you're a lumpy
purple death Titan Star Fox couldn't be
any more different from his brother
Thanos and that's probably a good thing
can you imagine if those parents had to
put up with not just one but two lousy
kids
Avengers end game brought plenty of
changes to the Earth's Mightiest Heroes
and one of the biggest was to Thor who
put on a lot of weight
fat Thor as he's being called is dealing
with a lot of depression and Trauma
here's his story from Black Panther's
anger after his father's murder to Iron
Man's post Avengers panic attacks to
Valkyrie abandoning Asgard and drowning
her sorrows the Marvel movies have often
dealt with the psychological trauma that
comes with the life of a superhero this
time though it's on a completely
different scale in the MCU the ending of
infinity war is unquestionably the
biggest tragedy in the history of the
planet it's not just the billions of
people turned to dust but as we see an
end game it's all life meaning that
Thanos took out animals too it's
devastating for the entire universe and
the heroes who are at the center of it
are no exception when the film shifts
its focus to five years after the snap
we see that each of the Avengers has
been dealing with the trauma in a
different way even before we get to Thor
it's not always healthy in what's
probably the most productive response we
see Captain America leading a support
group for survivors which works on a lot
of levels it highlights the empathy and
moral scent that makes Steve Rogers such
an appealing character and works as a
tribute to his Fallen Friend Sam Wilson
before he was an Avenger Sam was leading
a support group for veterans and with
him gone cap is doing his best to carry
on that Legacy the others however aren't
doing so well in the way they deal with
tragedy Hawkeye goes to an incredibly
violent extreme trying to personally
enforce a fairness that's absent in the
loss of innocent life Black Widow loses
herself in obsessing over her work
trying to fix everything she can while
Tony Stark's life postnap is far more
idyllic than the other Heroes he's still
completely given up making the world a
better safer place which defined his
life as Iron Man he's refusing to use
his genius to help others because well
what's the point he tried it didn't work
time to move on these are all very
different and very relatable ways of
dealing with a traumatic experience
Bruce Banner's reaction to the snap is
worth paying close attention to both
because it represents the biggest change
for one of the characters and because of
the relationship he's had with Thor
throughout the history of the MCU since
they first slugged it out on the
Helicarrier back in the first Avengers
film they've been competitors and the
Buddy comedy of Thor Ragnarok put them
in direct contrast with each other it's
come up several times throughout the
films that since they hadn't met Captain
Marvel yet they both consider themselves
to be the strongest Avenger welcome
strongest Avenger oh what for all their
similarities it's how they react to
their failures that shows how different
they really are since his character is
entirely built around making explosive
anger and the reaction to trauma a
literal physical change it makes sense
that it's the Hulk that we first see
reacting to the devastation that comes
along with Thanos this Unstoppable force
of nature comes up against something he
can't beat through strength in Infinity
War Polk learns the same thing Thor
learns at the beginning of end game
sometimes physical strength is
completely meaningless and that's a
devastating lesson for someone who
relies on that strength as one of their
defining characteristics for the Hulk
the initial reaction is another one of
those unhealthy coping tactics he runs
away and hides he won't even Hulk out
when his life's in danger leaving Bruce
Banner free of his dark side for the
first time in years instead of accepting
this thing he's wanted Banner comes to
understand that the Hulk is a part of
him and as a result he spends the
five-year Gap essentially going through
the gamma-powered superheroic version of
therapy and working through his issues
to unify his personalities 18 months in
a gambling I put the brains and the bra
and they get it and now look at me
Best of Both Worlds back in the first
Avengers film Bruce Banner gave us the
iconic line that summed up his struggle
with his emotions
I'm always angry
the Hulk we have an end game however is
no longer driven by anger he has young
fans that want to take pictures with him
and he shares his lunch with Ant-Man in
a scene that's far more than just a
Punch Line This is a brand new version
of the Hulk one who's not just smart but
kind and generous instead of being a
mindlessly angry walking temper tantrum
with the potential to destroy a city for
the first time in the franchise Bruce
Banner is happy because he's learned and
worked to change himself unfortunately
that's one thing Thor can't do in a lot
of modern stories about mythological
characters including recent comics about
Thor the idea is that the gods are the
embodiments of ideas unlike humans they
can't change their nature okay I thought
the world here
I thought what I'm gonna find side by
side forever but at the end of the day
you're you and I'm me Thor is the God of
Thunder who storms in with a bolt of
lightning and a booming Hammer laying
waste to his enemies he's an almost
effortlessly powerful Warrior and the
entire Arc of Ragnarok is devoted to the
way he learns that his strength and
power come from within himself not from
any of his magic weapons it's his
defining feature so what happens when it
doesn't work in endgame Thor sees
himself as personally responsible for
failing to kill Thanos before he could
snap and when he finally did finish off
the Mad Titan it was too late to fix
anything he goes through almost the same
thing that the Hulk does except that
he's made to watch as the last remnants
of his people are attacked and
eventually finds out that even his shiny
new Hammer Can't Stop Thanos in time for
all his strength he failed if his
strength defines him but it couldn't
save the billions of lives lost in
Infinity War what's the point that's the
existential crisis Thor's dealing with
in endgame when we meet back up with
Thor five years after the snap he's
almost completely inert that's a very
common and very relatable symptom of
depression and so is the idea that he's
not just sitting around in the dark
being sad for all the films over-the-top
visuals and jokes about his weight the
movie isn't a cartoonish portrayal of
what it's like to deal with depression
we see Thor laughing and hanging out
with his friends but when he's
confronted with the idea that he could
do something important the same thing
he's failed at before it just doesn't
matter there's another element of his
depression that manifests itself in the
film too he's become an alcoholic Thor's
legendary appetite for beer has always
been a source of comedy in the MCU films
I don't drink tea what do you drink not
tea endgame shows us the darker side of
that like a lot of people with
depression including Valkyrie and
Ragnarok Thor is self-medicating and his
physical change is the result of that
sadly that's a pretty relatable element
for a lot of viewers too one of the
reasons Thor's new body was such a
surprise is that unlike a lot of
endgame's other callbacks there's no
precedent for it in the comics Thor has
undergone plenty of changes over the
years including the time he was a six
foot six frog for a few issues but he's
always been drawn with the heroic
proportions that you'd expect as far as
his mental state the closest we've
gotten to seeing a truly depressed Thor
came when we got a glimpse of a distant
future where Thor was the last surviving
his Guardian like his movie counterpart
all father Thor was dealing with
isolation depression and the toll of
Millennia a battle that left him with
one arm and one eye the main difference
was that this Thor was more than willing
to take up his hammer and fight although
his goal was a glorious death in battle
that doesn't mean the Thor Comics have
been free of fat jokes for decades one
of the most prominent members of Thor's
Supporting Cast was volstag the
voluminous one of the Warriors Three
he's a once mighty warrior whose
waistline is just as expanded as the
inflated Tales of his glory while
volstag was often depicted as a braggart
and more than a little cowardly he's
also always been a very positive
character who comes through in dire
situations also in an interesting
contrast of what we see with Thor he
once survived the destruction of Asgard
only to waste away from lack of food
before Thor found him and nicknamed him
volstag the thin all of that forms the
background but for some members of
endgame's audience the possible intent
doesn't matter as much as what makes it
to the screen the simple fact is that
the reveal of fat Thor is absolutely
played for laughs and Thor's body is
used as a frequent punchline there are
cracks from our heroes about Thor having
cheese whiz running through his veins
and even the scene with his mother one
of endgame's most emotional sequences
ends with Friga telling him to eat a
salad part of that undoubtedly comes
from the fact that over the past decade
Thor has evolved into a much more
comedic character than he might have
been if Chris Hemsworth didn't turn out
to have a talent for comedy I dropped
I trapped I went to pick up the snake to
admire it and he transformed fact into
himself and he was like yeah it's me and
he stopped me that said once he's done
playing fat Thor Hemsworth gets to go
back to being well Chris Hemsworth the
fat jokes are bound to sting regardless
but coming from a dude known for being
super heroically ripped and ridiculously
handsome it definitely feels like he's
punching down for some viewers the jokes
at Thor's expense were easy to forgive
not only did they see Thor's depression
and its results is relatable but the
fact that his fellow Avengers are
lashing out is an equally realistic
depiction of how people around them can
react under stress these characters have
always been quick to get snarky with
each other and that's just part of their
appeal
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth but even within the
context of the film we're still seeing
superheroes the ultimate good guys
making fun of someone's appearance
context is important but it's always
worth remembering that this is fiction
and calling anything realistic doesn't
hold much water in a movie where a guy
with rocket boots uses magic space rocks
to fight a seven foot purple alien for
some critics it just raises the question
of whether we would have lost anything
if it hadn't been there or if Thor's
Depression had been shown in some other
way the flip side to the anger is that
for all of its flaws and the sniping
from other characters the action of the
movie never really presents Thor's body
as a problem the climax of that
emotional scene with Friga is the
present day post-snap Thor summoning
mjolnir and realizing that despite the
guilt he's been feeling for five years
he's still as worthy heroic and Noble as
he has always been most telling at the
end of the movie where he truly regains
his godly power and makes a stand
against Thanos he doesn't just magically
transform back into his usual muscular
body the only change to his physical
appearance is that his unkempt beard is
now neatly braided he's still as Hefty
as he was but he's also as strong as
ever as corny as it might sound all he
really needed was to talk to someone who
understands what he's going through the
fact that there's no physical difference
between the depressed apathetic Thor of
the beginning of the film and the hero
we see at the end seems to indicate the
filmmaker's sincerity in presenting the
depression not the weight gain as the
problem to be conquered still the jokes
at his expense are very much a part of
the film and it's hard to believe that
Thor won't be showing up in future MCU
films with his traditional jacked
bodybuilder physique the way it's
treated going forward is going to go a
long way in determining how audiences
look back on it here
Avengers in-game took secrecy to all new
levels with its intentionally
spoiler-free marketing efforts once the
movie was released though the behind the
scenes info began pouring out here are
some of the most interesting things to
emerge it's a well-known fact that
directors Joe and Anthony Russo will go
to extreme lengths to keep their Marvel
Creations under wraps for example they
teasingly apologized to the
spoiler-prone Tom Holland for dusting
Spidey at the end of infinity war and
consequently keeping him at arm's length
for the promotion of end game they also
pretended to fire Mark Ruffalo after a
string of spoilers had put him on thin
ice one of the best methods for keeping
everyone in the dark though was the way
the russos handled the script most of
the actors got only pieces of the
screenplay to work from and apparently
Ruffalo got a particularly spoiler-proof
version of the script the Hulk actor was
only given a partial script with
additional dummy scenes in it according
to an interview with E news I don't know
what's gonna happen I'm like shot five
different endings
really I didn't even get a whole script
but even that didn't stop him from
accidentally giving something away in
that same interview he joked about what
he presumably thought was one of those
dummy scenes the spoiler and he gets
married in this we we kind of they have
to throw mark off The Descent oops in
game is the second MCU outing for Carol
Danvers who arrived on the scene just
weeks earlier in her own superhero flick
Captain Marvel for actress Brie Larson
though that wasn't the case Larson had
filmed her scenes for in-game before she
ever had a chance to flesh out the
character in her own film as an added
twist the first scene she ever filmed
was set during the events of in-game but
technically ended up in Captain Marvel
on The Tonight Show Larson recalled that
her first day of filming was for the end
credits scene for her own film which
showed her arriving at The Avengers
facility post Snap so what pan saman ago
where's Fury I didn't know there was a
tag for Captain Marvel I didn't know
what that was that we were shooting
there's also nobody else there in true
Russo fashion though the actress was
only given her lines and filmed her part
alone in front of a green screen that's
taking secrecy to a whole new level
while the Russo Brothers bend over
backwards to keep actors like Ruffalo
Holland and Larson from spoiling the
script there was one person that they
didn't mind showing the whole thing to
Robert Downey Jr while discussing
Infinity war and in-game in an interview
with Rotten Tomatoes the pair talked
about keeping things secret RDJ was
probably the only one to actually read
the entire script Evans might have read
part of our motivation to do that is it
just takes a lot of pressure off of
people everything had started with Iron
Man just a decade earlier with in-game
ultimately serving as the iron Avengers
swan song it's only appropriate that RDJ
would be trusted with some of the most
sensitive MCU knowledge to ever exist
when the Avengers break into teams for
their Time Heist and end game Rocket and
Thor are sent to Asgard during the
events of Thor the Dark World to
retrieve the reality stone at that point
in time the stone is using the god of
Thunder's X Jane Foster is a host Foster
who's been absent from Marvel films
since the Dark World appears on screen a
few times before rocket is able to get
the reality Stone out of her but it
turns out that Foster actress Natalie
Portman didn't actually film any new
footage for endgame in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly the russos
explained that they had been able to
salvage unused footage from the Dark
World in order to get all of the scenes
they needed while the footage was enough
for them to work with they did ask the
actress to record a small bit of voice
over in the days after end game lit up
the theater Marquees Star-Lord actor
Chris Pratt stirred up attention by
releasing a video he'd taken on set
while preparing for one of the film's
key action sequences the once in a
lifetime video showed nearly all of the
famous actors mostly in sweats and
comfortable clothing chatting and
discussing their scenes as casually as
if they were a group of high schoolers
hanging out after class the video gave a
unique glimpse into the inner workings
of a film that had been kept tightly
Under Wraps since day one Stan Lee was a
comic book Titan for over half a century
while he was an important creative mind
behind the scenes for decades his long
relationship with Marvel also led to a
memorable series of fan favorite cameos
throughout various movies when Lee
passed away in late 2018 fans began
theorizing about when his last Cameo
would surface a year earlier it had been
revealed that Lee had filmed five
different cameos for upcoming films the
fact that he was apparently batching his
cameos naturally left the possibility
that he could be popping into films for
an indefinite amount of time in-game
delivered a shot of a younger looking
hippie version of Lee driving by the
1970s Shield headquarters shouting Make
Love Not War as it turned out that scene
will be Lee's Last ever Cameo and it's a
fitting farewell the russos confirmed
after the fact that it's the last
Stanley Cameo that made it to film in a
Twist that few people saw coming in
in-game Natasha Romanov ended up
sacrificing herself for the Soul Stone
it was a beautifully Redemptive way to
end her own heroic story which had been
going on in the background for nearly
the entire MCU but of course this is
Marvel and there's always the question
of whether they'll bring her back with
gamora's re-entrance into the future
from the past in in-game anything is
possible except not with Roman her story
seems close for good this time
screenwriters Christopher Marcus and
Stephen mcfeely explain to the New York
Times her journey in our minds had come
to an end if she could get the Avengers
back she has a chance to get them back
that's a thing she would trade for
during her Memorial scene on the dock
the surviving Heroes conversation drove
home the point that the cost of the Soul
Stone is a permanent one while there's
no doubt that black widow will be
remembered by fans for years to come
she's gone for good except presumably
for her upcoming movie while Black Widow
may have ultimately been given a
powerful closing to her own story
romanov's Death wasn't always a sure
thing after all movies aren't completely
finished until the release date The
shawarma in credit scene from Avengers
wasn't even added until the week that
the film was released so it should come
as no surprise that there was a lot of
Shifting and changing as they went along
one of those changes the events on
bormir writers Marcus and mcfeely
explained that there was a version of
the script that had Clint Barton
sacrificing himself for the stone
instead of Romanov but when they gave
the scene to the visual effect
ex-producer Jen underdahl she apparently
told them don't you take this away from
her the response clearly impacted the
writers who ultimately acknowledged that
it had to be Romanov it turns out the
Marcus and mcfeely have had a working
Master document since Captain America
Civil War where they kept track of
different things they wanted to do with
their Heroes character arcs it turns out
that end game was the movie where they
got to run wild in particular mcfeely
said that they wanted to explore
Marvel's tradition of what if Comics
alternate universe presentations of
Marvel events playing out differently
the writers delve in and Incorporated a
bunch of what-if scenarios right into
the in-game plot the writers told the
New York Times well this is our what if
if you lost Thor becomes fat Natasha
becomes a shut-in Steve becomes
depressed Tony gets on with his life
Hulk is a superhero Clint becomes a
murdering Maniac while there were solid
reasons for every character's shift in
tone there's no doubt that the writers
were happy to push the heroes out of
their comfort zone for the entertainment
of all Infinity war and in-game may be
two distinctly different movies but the
subject matter that they handle is
clearly interwoven this left the writers
and directors constantly scrambling to
figure out how to puzzle a bunch of
different pieces of storyline together
in a coherent way that left them with
two distinct yet connected movies at one
point the plan was to have Hulk and
banner resolve their differences in
Infinity War however it felt like too
much of a positive in the middle of a
pretty sad ending so the filmmakers
bumped into end game they also left out
the actual transformation banking on
Scott Lang in the dinner scene to
provide the right amount of confusion to
help bridge the gap in the same vein
Hawkeye's opening scene in in-game where
he loses his family was nearly tacked
onto the end of infinity War but it once
again felt out of place the biggest
decision of all was where to place the
snap they debated putting it earlier in
Infinity War but it would have left
almost nothing for the ending on the
other hand if they pushed it to end game
it would have left the first movie with
no ending at all knowing when to reverse
the snap was nearly as challenging
thankfully the creative minds behind the
scenes managed to eventually pull it all
together into two coherent stories Scott
Lang was right end game is a Time Heist
movie it wasn't the writers who came up
with that one though but Marvel boss
Kevin feige himself feige's original
suggestion was to use time travel to
resolve the infinity War plot with the
centerpiece being the time Stone it
wasn't until the filmmakers began
fleshing things out that the quantum
realm became the key plot device to move
the time travel element forward once
time travel was in the mix there was one
obvious point that had to make it into
the film The Battle of New York but the
writers initially felt it was too
pandery to head back to the original
Avengers film so they tried a ton of
Alternatives first at one point they had
Tony Stark on Asgard in a stealth suit
fighting Heimdall and the planet Morag
was originally underwater at another
Point The Avengers stopped by triskelian
and even hopped in a car to visit Doctor
Strange when the rubber hit the road
though Riders and directors alike
finally decided that heading back to the
chittari infested Streets of New York
was the best option of the bunch the
sequence in in-game when our heroes put
their Heist plan to The Test shows the
time travel with in the MCU is
distinctly different than the way it's
been represented in movies like timecop
hot tub time machine or Back to the
Future
kind of a DeLorean it also establishes
that Pim particles are in extremely
limited Supply Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers head back on a potentially
one-way trip to the 70s in the hope of
scrounging up more particles just to
keep everything from falling apart this
left fans scratching their heads when
nebula casually brought thanos's entire
planet-sized ship in its massive Army
into the present where on Earth did they
get the impossibly huge number of
particles to pull off a stunt like that
Joe Russo cleared up the disconnect in
an interview offering an elegantly
Simple Solution when 2014 nebula
surrenders the Pim particles to her
father they aren't for him to use to
time travel they're for scientific
research Thanos a genius himself with
the help of the powerful sorcerer ebony
ma studied the Pim particles and then
mass-produced them in order to defeat
The Avengers once and for all
since his debut in 1962 The Mighty Thor
has been one of the Marvel universe's
most powerful Heroes even if you're
caught up on his adventures can recite
the inscription on his hammer for memory
and know the name of the magical medal
it was crafted from here are a few
things about Odin's favorite son that
you'd be surprised to learn
Kirby's three Thor's when Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby were creating the Marvel
Universe in the 60s they'd already been
working in comics for 20 years with that
in mind it might not be surprising that
journey into mystery number 83 wasn't
Kirby's first shot at doing a story
about the Norse god of thunder that
honor goes to Adventure Comics number 75
in a story by Kirby and his Captain
America collaborator Joe Simon the
Golden Age Sandman goes up against a
crook named fairy tale Fenton who
masquerades as the hammer swinging
Thunder God in order to pull off during
robberies after injuring the sandman's
sidekick and sparking a full-on riot
Fenton is finally brought down and sent
packing never to be seen again 15 years
later Kirby would hit a little closer to
the mark with tales of the unexpected
number 16. a six-page story called the
magic hammer featured a Thor with plenty
of familiar Design Elements and a
version of mjolnir that looks an awful
lot like the one that would show up at
Marvel at the start of the next decade
it was even hidden on Earth until it was
found by a mere mortal who could tap
into its power although in this case it
was discovered by a cowboy crook named
Bard who was anything but worthy the
real twist though while Kirby's third
shot at Thor would be a success for the
fledgling Marvel Comics both the Sandman
story and tales of the unexpected were
published by DC
journey into mystery building off the
success that they'd found by introducing
the Fantastic Four the previous year Lee
and Kirby decided in 1962 to expand
their superhero universe and the Mighty
Thor charged into the pages of journey
into mystery number 83. for the most
part the stone men from Saturn follows
the usual beats of the sci-fi monster
Comics that Marvel had been publishing
in the 50s aliens invade Earth but get
scared off when they encounter someone
who's strong enough to stand against
them the big difference is that the
someone is of course Dr Don Blake who
finds a cane tucked away in a cave in
Norway that can transform him into Thor
but there's another important character
who made his debut in that issue in 2006
the planet Hulk storyline revealed that
one of those Stone men from Saturn fled
back to the stars and wound up stranded
on the planet sakar living as a
gladiator his name was Korg and while a
similar rock monster appeared in the
open of Thor the Dark World and a
tribute to that first issue Korg himself
would wind up being a significant
character in Thor Ragnarok
Dr Don who
Marvel superheroes are often defined by
having disadvantages in their civilian
identities that bleed into their heroic
exploits Iron Man had to wear the chest
plate of his armor all the time in order
to keep the shrapnel from moving closer
to his heart Spider-Man was perpetually
broke and struggled with school for Thor
the consequence of losing control of his
hammer for 60 seconds was that he would
turn back into his human identity Dr
Donald Blake a disabled Doctor Who
worked with his nurse in love interest
Jane Foster in the 80s Marvel introduced
a big twist Don Blake didn't actually
exist instead Thor's human form was
created by Odin in order to teach his
son the Folly of his arrogance by
imprisoning him in the body of a human
Odin hoped that Thor would stop bragging
and learn to put the needs of others
before his own considering the stories
we've gotten since it's safe to say that
it worked
Tales of Asgard
while Thor himself was in the spotlight
Lee and Kirby added an awful lot to
Marvel's version of the Norse pantheon
to help distinguish it from the classic
mythology the tales of Asgard backup
stories adapted myths and helped
introduce new characters like fandral
The Dashing Hogan the Grimm and volstog
the voluminous better known as The
Warriors 3.
surprise
it everything you need to know about
these three characters is right there in
their names fandral is a swashbuckler
based on the on-screen exploits of Robin
Hood actor Errol Flynn while Hogan was a
fearsome fighter that according to Lee
was based on Charles Bronson full stag
was inspired by Falstaff from
Shakespeare's Henry IV an aging Warrior
who often exaggerated his own
accomplishments and was eventually
revealed to have an equally voluma
luminous wife and about a dozen kids the
Warriors 3 quickly became fan favorite
supporting characters and even managed
to spin off into a few stories focused
entirely on them as a leading Trio
the Thor core when Walt Simonson took
over Thor in 1983 for a truly definitive
run on the character one of the biggest
changes he made was the introduction of
Beta Ray Bill an alien every man who
looked like a cross between an orange
humanoid and a skeletal horse bill was
the chosen defender of his race as they
fled the destruction of their home
planet after a cosmic misunderstanding
led him into a brutal battle against
Thor he proved he was worthy to Hoist
the hammer and Odin granted him one of
his own Stormbreaker Bill wasn't the
only other Marvel character to ever
wield the power of Thor in 1988 Tom
DeFalco and Ron France gave Thor a new
secret identity in the form of Eric
Masterson an architect whose
inexperienced with Godly Powers gave him
a pretty big challenge in crime fighting
in 1993 two characters were separated
but Eric continued his heroic career as
thunderstrike wielding a magical mace
with the same name in Thor number 384
they introduced Dargo Couture a resident
of a 26th Century dystopia who lifted
mjolnir and became that era's version of
Thor needless to say he crossed over to
the core Marvel Universe to battle the
Fantastic Four on the orders of zarco
the tomorrow man no really that's the
actual name of a Marvel character with
all these thores running around at the
same time they obviously had to form a
team thus was born the Thor core in
which Thor Beta Ray Bill thunderstrike
and Dargo United for a battle across
time and space that would basically
prove how Wild comics in the 90s could
be
The Incredible Hulk Returns until the
launch of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
The Incredible Hulk TV show was one of
Marvel's greatest mass media successes
it ran for Five Seasons and gave the
Hulk one of the most memorable
catchphrases of all time don't make me
angry you wouldn't like me when I'm
angry when Bill Bixby and Lou ferigno
returned his banner and his green Alter
Ego for a series of TV movies Marvel
used that popularity to shift the
spotlight on a few of their other
characters the second trial of the
Incredible Hulk would use its courtroom
setting to introduce TV audiences to
Marvel's resident attorney Daredevil but
the first one hit the Incredible Hulk
against the Mighty Thor in this case
Thor was played by Eric Kramer and while
his TV appearance did include Don Blake
it wasn't as Thor's Alter Ego instead
Blake found himself in a sort of Aladdin
situation where Thor was compelled to do
his bidding leading to a pretty weird
scene where Blake and Thor hung out in a
bar trying to decide whether Thor should
take up a career as a crime fighter
Clore goes bad in 2006 the Marvel
Universe was divided in the Civil War
crossover on one side Iron Man was
pushing for and eventually enforcing the
Superhuman registration act which would
require all superheroes to sign up with
the government for training organization
and oversight on the other Captain
America and a band of rebels were
fighting against the shra in the name of
freedom and the slippery slope that
would inevitably lead to giant robots
rounding up mutants it stands to reason
that whichever side got Marvel's most
powerful Heroes would have a pretty big
Advantage but there was a problem the
Hulk was out in the depths of space and
Thor was temporarily no longer alive but
Tony Stark didn't let a problem like
that stop him with a strand of Asgardian
hair and some pseudoscience he and Reed
Richards were able to cook up the
pro-registration side's Ultimate Weapon
a cybernetic clone of Thor that was
quickly dubbed Clore given how well
cyborgs and clones have gone for her you
know the entire history of comics it
won't surprise you that clora went rogue
at his earliest opportunity and ended up
blowing a hole through a hero called
Goliath while Clore was smashed to bits
by Hercules at the end of Civil War he
was eventually rebuilt and christened
Ragnarok cropping up in the pages of
dark Avengers before the real Thor
returned to midgard and proved that
Ragnarok couldn't hold up to the genuine
article you should have brought more
Thor's Thor's identity has been pretty
malleable ever since Beta Ray Bill first
hefted the hammer back in 1983 but
recent stories have seen more people
claiming the title than ever before a
2013 story saw the arrival of Gore the
god butcher a cosmic threat so dire that
in order to defeat him Thor had to team
up with the greatest warriors he could
think of himself twice together with a
young Thor who had yet to prove himself
worthy of malnir and an older one-eyed
one-armed version who had taken Odin's
role as all father the United United to
defeat the god butcher it's a morgore
Thor core in 2014 after the odinson's
worthiness was called into question
mjolnir found a replacement in the form
of a new Thor one whose arrival changed
the inscription to read if she be worthy
this Thor's identity was initially
played as a mystery but was eventually
revealed to be the original Thor's
former love interest Jane Foster whose
mortal form was dying of cancer she
proved herself to be more than capable
of living up to her namesake but during
a desperate struggle against the
Monstrous man Gog she was only able to
defeat him by hurling mjolnir into the
sun apparently destroying it and ending
her own life in the process in Thor girl
we don't talk about Thor girl
Steve Rogers the World War II hero and
perennial Avenger known as Captain
America has been a cultural icon since
he was famously introduced punching
Adolf Hitler in the face on the cover of
Captain America Comics number one while
you might already know about his decades
spent as an icicle or his Frenemy
relationship with Iron Man there's
plenty of lesser-known details about the
Sentinel of Liberty here is the Untold
Truth of Captain America
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
he trains every avenger Captain America
is among the finest hand-to-hand
combatants in the Marvel Universe thanks
to his vast experience training and
enhanced strength and reflexes as such
he trains just about every hero who has
come through the Avengers revolving door
among his more interesting students the
Invincible Iron Man She-Hulk Hawkeye and
even Mary Jane Watson maybe he should be
called drill sergeant America your
fighting stylist to tackle people or
blast them if I had to guess I'd say
that you've never been in an actual
fight in your life
multiple buckies almost as well known as
cap himself is his original sidekick
Bucky Barnes Barnes was a mascot at the
military base where Rogers was stationed
in the early days of World War II who
was taken under the captain's Wings
Bucky was presumed dead along with cap
in the Fateful plane crash that led to
Cap's hibernation although the young
sidekick would return decades later as
the Winter Soldier
Rogers would eventually pick up another
young sidekick in the modern era Rick
Jones Rick Jones was directly involved
in the accident which created The Hulk
and it was his distress call which
initially caused The Avengers to form
having been taken in by the team as an
honorary member Jones answered the call
when Cat found himself in need of
another partner undergoing combat
training and even for a Time wearing
Bucky's old uniform the partnership
didn't last long but Rick Jones would
continue to be a sidekick for just about
everyone in the Marvel Universe replaced
by Black Panther in Avengers number 47
cap decides to take a leave of absence
from the team to set off on his own
Adventures a journey that would bring
him to wakanda where he would encounter
perhaps his only viable replacement in
Black Panther
tell me Captain America
is it really your Shield after helping
cap to foil a plot by Baron Zemo to
destroy the United States using Advanced
Weaponry t'challa accompanies cap back
to America mulling over his suggestion
to join the Avengers as Cap's
replacement t'challa quickly proves his
worth in a fight against the Grim Reaper
and The Grateful team makes t'challa a
full-fledged member after that cap would
only make Cameo appearances in Avengers
Comics until returning to the team a
full three years later the Falcon and
the Red Skull Sam Wilson the Falcon has
been capp's staunchest friend and Ally
over the years their formal partnership
began way back in 1971's Captain America
number 133 but strangely their long
Association never would have happened if
not for one of the red skull's mini evil
plots to kill Captain America in Captain
America number 117 Steve Rogers is
banished to a mysterious island after
getting his body switched with the Red
Skull while there cap disguises himself
as a normal guy and runs into Sam Wilson
a harlem bird Enthusiast who trains with
cap to become the Falcon together the
two of them foil the red skull's plot
cap gets his body back and Sam Wilson
embarks on a long crime fighting career
as the falcon
Captain America and the Captain
America's Steve Rogers might be the most
famous Captain America but he's far from
the only one after becoming
disillusioned with America and donning
the new identity of nomad Steve Rogers
left the Captain America identity
available and a trio of schmoes tried
out for the job while the first two
bailed after realizing just how perilous
the job was Roscoe Simmons received
training from the Falcon himself
unfortunately he met a gruesome end at
the hands of The Red Skull forcing
Rogers to return as Captain America to
end the skull's murderous wrath later
wracked by fear of compromising his
principles he surrendered the official
Captain America role to John Walker the
super Patriot in favor of operating
independently as the captain Walker even
kept Cap's Shield during this time while
Rogers used a replica John Walker would
later become U.S agent once Steve Rogers
returned to reclaim the shield and
trademark identity in addition both
Bucky Barnes and Sam Wilson have
likewise taken over the mantle but
Rogers has always found his way back
from Death retirement or even just comic
book limbo
just don't want to give up
will the real cap please stand up in
2016 Marvel used the relaunch title
Captain America Steve Rogers to
introduce the most insanely
controversial plot twist in a history
full of them at the issues end cap
suddenly murders his sidekick Jack Flagg
before uttering two words which had cab
fans the world over reeling in shock
hail Hydra it turned out that Rogers had
been reconstructed by a sentient version
of The Cosmic Cube after a near-death
experience unfortunately the Red Skull
had indoctrinated the cube in one of the
many times that he had wielded it
causing Roger's entire history to be
retconned as a hydra's secret agent as
you might expect the real Captain
America managed to escape his
imprisonment inside the Cube's memory
and promptly defeated his fascist
counterpart what makes a shield
is perhaps the most iconic tool in any
superheroes Arsenal not only is it
virtually indestructible it can absorb
vast amounts of kinetic energy which is
why it can withstand blows from the Hulk
or Thor without simply sending cap
flying in its original comic Incarnation
The Shield isn't pure vibranium but an
alloy accidentally created by scientist
Myron McLean in a metallurgical accident
McLean was tasked by the U.S government
with the creation of a super strong
metal to be used in tanks and one night
while laboring over the project McLean
fell asleep he awoke to find that the
materials he'd been working with had
mysteriously bonded and cast the new
substance using a disc shaped mold for
tank Hatches the government gifted cap
with a shield after he'd proven his
medal in the field and McLean was never
able to duplicate the process which
created it although repeated attempts
would years later result in the creation
of adamantium the famously strong medal
of which Wolverine's skeleton is made
replicas of Cap's Shield would be
employed for various purposes over the
years but cap always preferred the real
deal like the super soldier himself it's
one of a kind Shield throwing sense it's
a common misconception that Cap's Shield
must be equipped with some kind of
technology to make it return to him like
a boomerang but this isn't the case The
Shield's ability to absorb and disperse
kinetic energy means that once bounced
off an object it will basically keep
bouncing Forever Until caught and Cap's
understanding of its properties enable
him to predict its flight path with
unerring accuracy handling it properly
is practically a superpower unto itself
to the point where even the two most
accomplished Heroes to take up Cap's
mantle Sam Wilson and Bucky Barnes both
struggled mightily to learn how to use
it as an offensive weapon even with
extensive training from Rogers however
there is one Avenger for whom handling
the shield wasn't much of a problem
Clint Barton Hawkeye perhaps the one
hero whose Mastery of physics and
ballistics is on par with caps leave it
to the most underrated Avenger to
measure up to Cap's exacting standards
[Music]
winning over audiences with his
joyfulness hyper literal language and
sense of loyalty the interstellar
Warrior Drax the Destroyer is one of the
brightest figures in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you couldn't quite
say the same for his comic book
counterpart in many ways Dave Batista's
interpretation of Drax is barely
recognizable from the character in the
comics and for once that's not a bad
thing since his debut in 1973's Iron Man
number 55 Drax the Destroyer has gone
through drastic shifts in intelligence
temperament and physical power he's been
one of Marvel's most powerful Heroes and
he's also been one of its dumbest he's a
character who has literally lived many
lives so the fact that the Drax of the
movies feels like a completely different
person is in keeping with a long
tradition of reinvention from his quest
for vengeance against Thanos to his
surprising connection to the planet
Earth here is everything you need to
know about Drax the Destroyer nothing
goes over my head my reflexes are too
fast
where I'm from drax's origin story
appeared in 1974's Captain Marvel number
32 written by Jim Starlin in the issue
readers learn about the hero's Homeworld
and it's the last place you'd expect
Earth as originally written by Starland
Drax was a human being by the name of
Arthur Douglas who had a wife named
Yvette and a daughter Heather during
thanos's first scouting mission to Earth
Arthur and his family had the bad luck
to be on the road in the Nevada desert
as the Titan flew behind his ship Thanos
attacked fatally wounding Arthur Andy
vet unbeknownst to anyone Heather
escaped but we'll have more to say about
her later after the incident thanos's
father Mentor called out to Chronos
father of the Gods for help in stopping
his Wayward Son Kronos obliged mentor
and built a super powerful body which he
used as a vessel for Arthur's Soul
Arthur Douglas may have been no more but
his Sole and sense of Vengeance lived on
in a new form Drax it's a vastly
different origin story in the MCU in
Guardians of the Galaxy drax's comic
book Origins as a human man are
completely ignored instead of Yvette and
Heather he had a wife named hovat and a
daughter named komaria both of them met
their ends thanks to Ronan the Accuser
acting on orders from Thanos what were
they like
my wife and daughter
they were
kind Brave
true the rewrite of the origin story is
a simple but effective change the movie
version keeps drax's thirst for
vengeance just without the complicated
wrinkle of extraterrestrial
reincarnation I kind of feel like Drax
is now mine
power levels as far as his strength is
concerned the Drax of the movies is
fairly middle tier you certainly
wouldn't want to arm wrestle him but he
also better not get on the Hulk's bad
side that wasn't always the case as the
Drax of the comics has occasionally been
one of Marvel's most powerful
superheroes the Destroyer has regularly
held his own against the absolute A-list
of Marvel tough guys including Thor the
Silver Surfer and the Hulk along with
having a lot more strength the Drax of
the comics used to have the power of
flight regularly flying through space
without a helmet or spacesuit he also
had the ability to fire powerful energy
blasts from his hands the Drax of the
panels became more like what we see in
the movies in 2005's Drax the Destroyer
miniseries after having one body
destroyed in the second issue Drax was
reborn smaller and less physically
powerful but with a much greater degree
of intelligence than the Vengeance
driven brute he used to be
bring me Thanos even though destroying
thanos's drax's sole purpose he hasn't
proven himself to be particularly good
at his job in drax's earliest
appearances his obsession with Thanos is
so intense that he can be as much of a
liability to the heroes on his side as a
help he cares little about plans schemes
or strategies he simply throws himself
at the Mad Titan when he reappeared
after a long absence in 1990 Silver
Surfer number 37 he attacked everyone in
sight screaming wears Thanos over and
over not listening or caring about the
fact that no one knew the answer in
2006's Annihilation number four after
over three decades of trying and failing
Drax finally managed to exact his
Vengeance against Thanos naturally he
just had to do it while Thanos was
trying to save the Galaxy during one of
his rare good guy turns as Thanos Works
to stop the villain annihilus from
destroying all life in the universe Drax
decides his vengeance is more important
and punches thanos's heart out of his
chest sure the timing of it was pretty
bad but you can't blame a guy for doing
what he was born to do my daughter
Moondragon in the comics Drax eventually
learns that his daughter Heather
survived the attack in the desert
rescued by thanos's father Mentor
Heather was brought to Titan and raised
there by a group of powerful monks where
she developed the powers of a superhero
taking on the name moon dragon though
moon dragon would eventually join the
Avengers The Defenders the infinity
watch and even the Guardians of the
Galaxy she didn't always share the most
heroic values of her comrades sometimes
she acted downright evil while traveling
through space with Drax she came across
a planet immersed in war and solved the
problem by mentally enslaving all the
inhabitants to help persuade his
daughter to take another course of
action Drax contacted the Avengers for
help along with a mind-controlled Thor
Moondragon fought against Drax and
succeeded in defeating him it was the
ultimate Injustice he was felt by his
own daughter and didn't even really
deserve it you people have issue use
well of course I have issues that's my
freaking father as you might imagine
Drax and moon dragon's relationship has
been pretty strained ever since
the idiot when Drax returned to life in
Silver Surfer number 35 his mind wasn't
fully healed though still intent on
securing thanos's destruction The
Intergalactic Warrior came back a little
more lovable and a whole whole lot
Dumber drax's diminished IQ was used for
comedic purposes with his brute strength
and odd passions being mined for Laughs
when Adam Warlock arrives to recruit
tracks for a new team drax's busy
smashing TV monitors because he's angry
the transmission of the earth show Alf
has been interrupted drax's mind didn't
stay dull forever but his intelligence
wasn't restored fully in a way that
stuck until 2005's Drax the Destroyer
miniseries no matter what intelligence
level he's been at though he's always
remembered how to play a mean sax
a cosmic custodian the conclusion of The
Infinity Gauntlet story left the
gauntlet and its six GEMS under the
guardianship of Adam Warlock Marvel's
Cosmic Pantheon wasn't happy with this
Arrangement however and encouraged him
to share the burden keeping the soul gem
for himself Adam chose five people to be
the Guardians of the remaining gems
creating a team known as the infinity
watch warlock would later wonder if he
had made the right decisions with the
people he chose to carry the gems
fearing the influence of The Infinity
Gauntlet had corrupted his judgment it's
no surprise why he thought this he gave
the Space Jam to the mischievous pip the
troll who immediately used it to steal
among other things in Avengers quinjet
the Mind gem went to Moondragon a woman
you'll recall once used her powers to
enslave an entire world the reality Jim
went to Thanos of all people finally
Adam gave the power gym to Drax the
dimwitted brute who destroys things when
he misses an episode of Alf good
leadership Adam
famously huge the movie drags as an
alien while the comic book drags as an
Earthling who is forced into a
constructed body this naturally means
there are a number of differences
between them one of the more surprising
differences well there's a specific
bodily function comic book tracks
doesn't have to worry about in the
beginning of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
2 rocket threatens to fill up Peter
Quill's pillow with fecal matter while
he sleeps because that's the kind of
mature and responsible team the
Guardians are you put your turd in my
bed I shave you oh it won't be my turn
it'll be draxxas
I have famously huge turds believe it or
not this is an invention specific to the
movies in the comics the size of drax's
bowel movements isn't any sort of Legend
as it turns out he doesn't have them at
all in warlock in the infinity watch
number two when Adam Warlock gives Drax
the power gym Drax doesn't know what to
do with it thinking he's been handed to
Jelly Bean he promptly eats it
understandably Gamora freaks out and
warlock tries to reassure her reminding
her that the gym is indestructible and
won't digest when she continues to
protest warlock says drax's physical
being is unlike most creatures I'll
explain later trust me he won't lose it
in other words the Drax of the comic
books doesn't poop no wonder he seems so
much happier in the movies
thanos's adopted daughter is the
highlight of almost every Guardians of
the Galaxy story she appears in but if
you only know Gamora from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you're missing out
she's much more than a world-class
assassin she's also a time traveler a
mother a fashion icon and a lover and
she's wielded one of the most powerful
weapons ever made gamora's comic
backstory is full of twists and turns
that are crazy in all the best ways
there's a reason Gamora is called the
most dangerous woman in the universe
let's take a look at some of the story
elements you might not know about
Marvel's green super heroine unfortunate
origin in the MCU gamora's origin is
pretty straightforward her planet was
wiped out by Thanos who rescued her and
raised her to be a warrior she
eventually turned on Thanos teamed up
with Star-Lord rocket Drax and Groot and
the rest is history in the comics Gamora
first appeared in Strange Tales number
180. but we don't learn her history
until warlock number 10 as The Story
Goes Thanos correctly predicted that the
villainous made just time warped version
of hero Adam Warlock and leader of the
tyrannical Universal Church of Truth
threatened his plans for Galactic
domination so Thanos needed a weapon he
could use to stop Mages before he grew
too powerful he found one in the future
years after warlock number 10 takes
place Mages soldiers killed gamora's
kinsfolk the pacifist Zen huberis as
part of their Crusade Thanos however
managed to rescue Gamora at the last
minute took her to the present and
trained her to stop Mages once and for
all her assassination attempt fails and
Gamora flat out perishes after turning
on Thanos but she still helps Adam
Warlock beat Mages in the church anyway
unseen action like her origin story
gamora's earliest days are pretty
confusing after two appearances and
Strange Tales her story moves into the
Warlock Standalone series then the
struggle between Thanos Adam and Gamora
concludes an Avengers annual number
seven and Marvel two-in-one annual
number two as a result of all this
ping-ponging between different books
there's one big hole while Gamora
eventually learns about thanos's true
nature and betrays him we never actually
see the whole story in warlock number 15
Gamora is tasked by Thanos to hunt down
Adam Warlock but is attacked on Route by
Drax but then the series ends next we
see her she's been left for dead by
Thanos himself so what happened seeing
Gamora betray her surrogate father
should have been a real big moment but
it was reduced to three flashback panels
according to Author Jim Starlin warlock
was ultimately canceled due to poor
sales so he had limited pages to wrap
the story up which meant supporting
characters like Gamora got the short end
of the stick leaving her Epic family
drama as a footnote nine lives Gamora
might be good at taking lives but that
doesn't mean she hasn't lost her own a
time or two when she was a kid she snuck
out against thanos's wishes on the
planet tartunla number seven and got
attacked and slaughtered by a roving
street gang Thanos had to rebuild her
from artificial parts and she lost her
tear ducts in the deal we also see
Gamora die in Avengers annual number
seven and while her body perishes her
soul is saved by Adam Warlock but her
spirit along with warlocks and pipped
the trolls ended up safely ensconced
inside the soul gem one of the Infinity
Stones she returns to Life In The
Infinity Gauntlet number one published
about 14 years later but there's a catch
her soul is put into the corpse of a
woman named Bambi long even when Gamora
is alive she's still technically not
when Thanos uses The Infinity Gauntlet
to end half of the life in the universe
Gamora bites it again although nebula
resurrects her and everyone else in
other words Gamora might be one of the
strongest heroes in the universe her
life tends to come and go
gem carrier so far Marvel's movies have
been all about the Infinity Stones six
brightly colored and infinitely powerful
rocks that act as the macguffins for the
entire MCU The Red Skull used one to
fuel his super weapons Loki scepter held
the Mind Stone which later ended up
bringing the vision to life the reality
Stone pops up in Thor the Dark World the
time Stone plays a crucial role in
doctor strange and the Power Stone is
the thing that drives the action in
Guardians of the Galaxy the infinity
gems have comic book counterparts of
course although on the printed page
they're better known as the soul or
infinity gems they've been around since
1972 and they play a big role in
Infinity Gauntlet which is a foundation
for Avengers Infinity War it's not just
Thanos that wielded the gems however
after Infinity Gauntlet Adam Warlock
took control of the infinity gems but
higher Powers than him decided that it
was too much power for one person to
handle and distributed the gems among
some of Marvel's Cosmic Heroes including
Gamora as part of the super team known
as Infinity watch Gamora was entrusted
with guarding the time gem now Gamora
didn't actually know how to use the time
gem although she'd occasionally get
prophetic Visions thanks to the Gem's
influence and she eventually gave up her
duties and left the watch the gems were
stolen and infinity watch disbanded
shortly thereafter
Mommy Dearest
by now you might have noticed that Adam
Warlock plays a big part in gamora's
pre-guardian's life given the laws of
comic book relationships that means
they'll inevitably hook up Warlock and
Gamora didn't just become a couple
however he'll actually have a child
together albeit an adopted one in
Infinity Abyss Jim starlin's 2002 entry
into his long-running Infinity Saga five
clones of Thanos called the thanosi set
out to kill Thanos and destroy the
universe naturally warlock Gamora and
their friends try to stop them the key
to the thanosi scheme is an all-powerful
being called Atlas the anchor of reality
since the days of the Roman Empire when
Atlas realizes his time is running out
he realizes he needs to pass on his
knowledge to a human girl named atlasa
who was born for this purpose there's
just one problem that lezza is still a
little girl Gamora and her buddies end
up defeating the thanosi but at lezza
who's kind of overwhelmed with her
Newfound Cosmic Powers he's training as
such Gamora and warlock retire to a
pocket Dimension to teach her the ways
of the universe while also serving as
her foster parents it's one of the
weirdest families imaginable but for
Warlock and Gamora weird is an everyday
thing with the two of them at her side
Atlas should be just fine
Monica Rambo might have debuted in
Captain Marvel as an excitable kid but
in the comics she's a heroine in her own
right in fact Monica might be one of the
most powerful superheroes in the Marvel
Universe this is her story
Monica made her debut in 1982's Amazing
Spider-Man Annual number 16. in this
issue fans are introduced to the spunky
future Avenger as Lieutenant Rambo an
officer climbing the ranks of the New
Orleans Harbor Patrol while on a mission
Rambo takes a direct shot of extra
dimensional energy from a criminal
scientist's mysterious machine as a
result she is granted incredible power
over energy Monica is able to generate
it manipulate it absorb it and even
transform her body into pure energy
which enables her to travel at
astonishing speed through the vacuum of
space after this incident Monica
encounters some thieves who try to steal
her purse while chasing them down she
accidentally gets into a minor fight
with Spider-Man who's surprised at the
amount of power she's packing but after
the misunderstanding is cleared up
Spidey along with an assist from Iron
Man and the WASP helps her gain better
control over her volatile Newfound
Powers while Monaco was not the first
Marvel character to debut in his
Spider-Man comic the issue marks the
start of a strong friendship between the
lieutenant and the wall crawler the two
would team up in many future comics
fans of the MCU might identify Carol
Danvers brought to life on screen by
Oscar winner Brie Larson as the one and
only Captain Marvel but off-screen this
couldn't be more incorrect within the
pages of Marvel Comics The Captain
Marvel name has a long history dating
back to the 1960s originating with the
Earthbound Cree Warrior Marvel Carol
Danvers is actually the seventh
character to take up the mantle and
she's certainly not the first woman to
do it the first female hero to be known
by the name of Captain Marvel was
actually none other than Monica Rambo
who was the second person to take on the
mantle it's the media who originally
dubs Monica Captain Marvel astonished by
her energy-based abilities but curiously
her take on the name has nothing to do
with Marvel or the cree makes sense
perfectly not confusing you can draw a
straight line from Carol danvers's
powers to the original Marvel but
Monica's powers and origin story come
from a completely different Source
meaning that in Marvel Comics Canon the
fact that they shared a name is actually
just a giant confusing coincidence
although she goes on to change her hero
names several times throughout the years
Monica will always be remembered as the
first woman to kick butt as Captain
Marvel
Rambo has made many lasting marks on the
history of the Marvel Universe when the
Avengers made her a full-fledged member
in 1983's Avengers number 231. Monica
officially became the first
African-American woman to join the
team's ranks although she was then still
pretty new to the superhero life both
wasp the team's leader at the time and
Captain America her second in command
admired Monica's powerful abilities and
Ironclad composure Monica wasn't the
first African-American heroine to join a
Marvel super team that honor goes to
Aurora Monroe better known as the
weather manipulating mutant storm who
made her comic debut in 1975's
giant-sized X-Men number one in joining
The Avengers Monica continued a proud
history and blazed a trail into the
future
throughout the years a plethora of
Marvel Superheroes have led the Avengers
ranging from popular characters like
Luke Cage to lesser-known types like Dr
Druid Carol Danvers then working as Ms
Marvel has actually led the team before
herself but as it turns out she isn't
the only Captain Marvel to earn that
particular distinction Captain America
actually nominates Monica Rambo then
still known as Captain Marvel for the
team's leadership role in 1987's
Avengers number 279 after then later
wasp decides to step down during her
time in charge Rambo's Avengers battle
Greek gods as well as Ames Cosmic
cuban-powered nightmare robot super
adaptoid although being in charge
certainly suits her Monica's reign as
the leader of the Avengers comes to an
abrupt end about a year after her
inauguration after a debilitating
accident drains her powers and nearly
kills her Dr Druid takes over after she
resigns and let's just say doesn't do
such a great job
Marvel has chosen some pretty strange
characters to put into the spotlight
over the years ever heard of Maverick an
energy absorbing mutant who like
Wolverine went through the Weapon X
Program probably not but he got his own
12-issue comic run in 1997. what about
Warlock the shape-shifting alien and
X-Men affiliate who got his own nine
issue run in 1999 no well perhaps you're
familiar with the craptacular b-sides a
gang of New Jersey teenagers with powers
like owning an actually magical magic
eight ball no well they too got their
own solo series back in 2002 and
craptacular is right there in their name
given how unheard of most of these
characters are it's surprising to the
Casual fan that they've ever been given
their own comic it's even more shocking
when you consider the fact that Monica
Rambo who leads the freaking Avengers at
one point has never been given her own
solo series sure she had a pair of
One-Shot issues as Captain Marvel one in
1989 and one in 1994 but never her own
multi-issue run this is a snub of Epic
Proportions considering Monica's major
significance in the Marvel Universe
throughout the years
superheroes tend to go through a lot of
names over the years sometimes it's to
disguise their identity as when Hawkeye
reborn after the events of the House of
M storyline decides to go by Ronan
sometimes it's to take up the mantle of
another Hero's Legacy as when the mutant
assassin psylocke takes on the Captain
Britain name after her brother retires
from the role and then sometimes your
Monica Rambo and all bets are absolutely
off the one-time Captain Marvel has
changed her vigilante Alias more times
than most fans can keep track of it
begins when she gives the Captain Marvel
title to Marvel's son genus Val in honor
of his father's Legacy and chooses to
become Photon instead however this isn't
the only time that genus makes things
difficult for poor Monica as he later
starts going by Photon too instead of
fighting him for the name Rambo simply
changes hers to Pulsar although she goes
by the name of Pulsar for a while Monica
eventually settles on the name of
spectrum as Spectrum Monica plays in
important role on Luke Cage's Mighty
Avengers team at one point even going
Toe to Toe with the powerful child of
Thanos Proxima midnight fingers crossed
that Spectrum sticks because her costume
is undeniably cool and honestly doesn't
Monica deserve a little stability in her
life
Monica Rambo's time as photon is
relatively uneventful with one very
important exception in the pages of next
wave agents of hate a hilariously
self-aware over-the-top comic series
written by Warren Ellis in which Monica
gets to be wild weird and wonderful not
to mention she acts as the leader of the
Agents of hate an acronym for highest
anti-terrorism effort adding yet another
entry onto her long list of
accomplishments joining Monica is an
assortment of minor Marvel characters
including x-force's Tabitha Smith the
Monster hunting Elsa Bloodstone machine
man and a foul-mouthed newbie who simply
goes by the captain the book is very
much a parody of a Marvel comic with
hate being an obvious play on Shield
because of this it shows off a rarely
seen funny side of Rambo who is right at
home leading a gang of marvelous Misfits
in the sprawling world of comic books
determining the most powerful Marvel
Superhero is a complicated task Thor and
talk are pretty popular choices but some
would argue villainous candidates like
Galactus and apocalypse are actually
stronger while she might not be the
first name that comes to mind Monica
Rambo is a contender as well her
energy-based powers don't just make her
a formidable force to be reckoned with
they might also make her Immortal in
2019's Avengers no Road home Monica now
Spectrum has a deeply philosophical
discussion with vision about the
inevitability of human death Rambo is
quick to point out that her body is
actually a vessel of pure energy so
technically she cannot die does this
make her less human she and vision come
to agree that only they can determine
the answer for themselves what is clear
however is the extent of Monica's
abilities she could live for decades
even centuries protected from Battle old
age and general wear and tear
even the most powerful superheroes have
a weakness Superman's notorious Achilles
heel is Kryptonite Luke Cage's
impenetrable skin is susceptible to
adamantium and Wolverine's healing
abilities are rendered ineffective when
the injury is dealt with by the muramasa
blade it's a long story although she
might be vastly powerful even Monica
Rambo winds up on death's doorstep every
once in a while in 1988's Avengers
number 293 and number 294 Namor the
submariner's wife Marina Smallwood
transforms into a gigantic sea monster
leaving The Avengers to hunt her down
when they find her Monica turns herself
into a bolt of electricity in order to
stop the deadly creature unfortunately
when she contacts the water she
accidentally conducts herself across the
entire ocean when her fellow Avengers
find her she is shrunken and near
lifeless although she lives through the
traumatic experience she temporarily
loses her powers leaving her no option
but to quit the superhero game and
resigned from The Avengers Monica
eventually regains her abilities but not
until after a long time spent being
haunted by the painful way she nearly
lost her life water and electricity
certainly don't mix especially when
you're an energy-based superhero
superheroes hooking up with other
superheroes is as much a part of the
genre as the origin story Luke Cage
loves Jessica Jones Kitty Prides has a
history with Colossus and Rogan Gambit
have actually managed to get married
likewise Monica Rambo has shared
intimate moments with a couple of
Supermen throughout the years 2009's
limited series Marvel Divas features
Monica teaming up with fellow gal Pals
Hellcat Firestar and black cat here it
is revealed that while helping cleanup
after Hurricane Katrina Monica and
Jericho drum the sorcerer better known
as brother Voodoo made a connection and
acted on it however the one-time
sorcerer Supreme isn't Monica's only
love interest during 2013's run of
Mighty Avengers Monica Now using the
name Spectrum gets injured fighting
Proxima midnight and has to be healed by
fellow Avenger Adam Brashear AKA blue
Marvel this leads to a very strong
relationship and one heck of a power
couple blue Marvel powers include Cosmic
intelligence anti-matter manipulation
and energy control
although she makes her debut as a kid in
Captain Marvel Monica Rambo's pardon the
Colossal MCU is set to extend far beyond
her childhood her next appearance will
come in the upcoming Disney plus series
one division with mad men's Tiana Paris
cast as a grown-up version of the
character
if you're confused by how Monica's
inclusion will make sense in this series
you're not alone heck everything about
one division is still shrouded in
mystery including the very premise of
how Vision who is presumably destroyed
by Thanos in Avengers Infinity War comes
back from the dead Marvel's promos for
this show only introduced more questions
showcasing various scenes of Paul
bettany's vision and Elizabeth Olsen's
Scarlet witch from seemingly different
time periods throw Monica Rambo into the
mix and you've got one serious head
scratcher this is gonna be a guess
leaked set photos of paris's Rambo
wearing a blue sword jacket seemingly
confirmed that she will be working for
or with the space-based task force which
has yet to make an appearance in the MCU
fans will just have to wait and see how
it all comes together when one division
hits Disney Plus
the Incredible Hulk is one of Marvel's
oldest and most recognizable icons
created by Comics Legend Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and first appearing in 1962's
Incredible Hulk number one the green
Goliath spawned hundreds of comics two
live-action movies a popular live-action
TV show and multiple animated series
films and video games and most
importantly big foam hands that make
smashy sounds when you hit things with
them
[Music]
with so much Hulk over so much media
it's almost impossible for even the most
hardcore fans to keep up with all the
stories here's the Untold Truth of The
Incredible Hulk Banner smash one of the
strangest and most hilarious periods of
the Hulk's history was the reign of
savage Banner which turned the most
well-known Banner Hulk relationship on
its head toward the end of 1995's The
Incredible Hulk number 425 longtime Hulk
writer Peter David changed things up
after enjoying a few years in the Hulk's
body while retaining the intelligence of
Bruce Banner the Hulk transformed back
into Banner but gained the simple
mentality of the Hulk for the first time
in the history of the character anger
became the Hulk's greatest weakness
previously even after turning into the
Hulk the hero's strength would continue
to increase as he got angry now he
struggled to stay calm during fights
with the likes of Thor and man thing so
that he wouldn't get angry and transform
into the utterly helpless Bruce Banner
Bob Banner
there are a lot of differences between
the Incredible Hulk comic and the 70s
live action TV show one of the first
obvious differences is that the Hulk's
more human half in the show is named
David Banner rather than Bruce Banner
David David
come on Kenneth Johnson who developed
the Incredible Hulk show explained that
he changed the name because he didn't
like the comic book tradition of using
alliteration when naming characters and
I was looking to break away from that
tradition so that people wouldn't be
thinking comic book in any way when they
looked at the show regardless of the
reason Johnson isn't the first person
guilty of changing Bruce Banner's first
name that honor goes to Stan Lee Lee was
writing a lot of comics in the early and
mid 60s and used alliterative names for
his characters in part to help him
remember all the names unfortunately in
the case of the Hulk this led him to
mistakenly referring to Bruce Banner as
Bob Banner his solution announced a few
issues later in Fantastic Four number 28
was that the real full name of the hooks
more human Alter Ego was Dr Robert Bruce
Banner hilariously that wasn't Lee's
only name slip up which is why 1963 is
The Amazing Spider-Man featured a few
pages of some guy named Peter Palmer
red Hulk's real origin in 2008 Hulk was
relaunched with a creative team of Jeff
Loeb and Ed McGinnis the pair introduced
the world to the Red Hulk a malevolent
intelligent and vicious red-skinned
version of the Hulk who seemed like he
might be even more powerful than the
original
foreign
but in Hulk number 23 it was revealed
that the Red Hulk was General Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross the same Army General
who'd hounded the original Hulk for
years Believe It or Not Loeb wasn't the
first writer to think of a red Hulk
Kenneth Johnson who developed the 70s
Incredible Hulk show thought a red Hulk
made more sense since it's the color
most people associate with anger
but Stan Lee was adamant that the green
Hulk was too iconic an image to be
changed so they painted Lou Ferrigno
green and red Hulk went back into hiding
for another 30 years
many voices
while Lou Ferrigno voiced The Hulk for
the 90s Incredible Hulk cartoon and in
most Marvel Studios films featuring The
Hulk he wasn't the Hulk's voice in The
Incredible Hulk TV show the one where he
you know actually played the Hulk the
source of the 70s Incredible Hulk's
Grunts and growls was Ted Cassidy best
known as Lurch from The Addams Family
Cassidy also read the narration that
told the story of David Banner in the
beginning of each episode
scientist searching for a way to tap
into the hidden strengths that all
humans have after Cassidy passed away in
1979 Charles Napier replaced him as the
voice of The Incredible Hulk
psychic senses you might think the
Hulk's abilities are limited to the
physical but there's more to the big
green guy than just pounding on stuff
throughout his Comics The Hulk has shown
some strange almost psychic abilities
during one of the Hulk's first
encounters with Doctor Strange and
Marvel feature number one strange
learned that the Hulk could somehow see
and interact with Strange's astral form
Peter David later made use of this
ability hounding the Hulk with ghosts
both literal and metaphorical during his
run on Incredible Hulk on top of that
the Hulk is always instinctively known
how to return to the gamma bomb site
where he was created more than 100
issues later this was explained as being
a kind of psychic energy summons from
the Maestro a future version of the Hulk
who was defeated by being teleported
back in time to the gamma Bomb Blast but
this doesn't explain the Hulk's other
Geographic instincts such as Incredible
Hulk number 33 when the Hulk is able to
LEAP from the coast of wakanda and
instinctively know how to angle his jump
in order to land on a tiny atoll in the
middle of the ocean
War Horse
Beyond his ongoing rivalry with
Wolverine the Hulk doesn't have a lot of
connections with the X-Men so it would
likely surprise even Wolverine to know
that the Hulk was briefly The Herald of
one of their most powerful adversaries
apocalypse an Incredible Hulk number 456
apocalypse captured the Hulk and
transformed him into one of his four
horsemen making the Hulk the first
non-mutant character to be a Horseman of
Apocalypse apocalypse's transformation
included cybernetic implants in the
Hulk's brain a big sword and a
retractable metal whip the Hulk's added
power allowed him to easily dispatch
with the twin threats of Juggernaut and
the absorbing man either of which would
be a match for the Hulk on his own
X-Men destruction
World War Hulk X-Men wasn't the first
clash between the Hulk and Professor X's
students but it was definitely one of
the most Savage the Green Giant fought
one of the largest Gatherings of X-Men
imaginable and he took them down all of
them while Professor X was a member of
the Illuminati a secret cabal of
superheroes who were the Hulk's targets
during World War Hulk the Hulk traveled
to Xavier's School to confront him
rather than allow their mentor to be
taken prisoner the X-Men fought back at
first it was only a small Squad but soon
all the active X-Men were facing the
vengeful Hulk including X Factor and the
Juggernaut the Hulk eventually relented
but not before breaking both of
colossus's arms and liquefying
Wolverine's brain by punching him in the
head over and over again
I don't suppose you got any interest in
talking this out
trolled by Hawkeye even though Hawkeye
shot Bruce Banner in 2016's Civil War 2.
nobody would consider Hawkeye and the
Hulk to be Rivals still if you look at
the narrative history they do have a
kind of weird relationship with each
other specifically Hawkeye's always gone
out of his way to be a jerk to the Hulk
y really because from where I'm standing
you look more beat up than angry after
Hawkeye Rage Quit The Avengers he came
upon the Hulk battling the villain Zacks
an Incredible Hulk number 166. Hawkeye
was so determined to show his former
teammates what he was made of that he
followed and pestered the Hulk all the
way into the pages of Defenders number
seven he annoyed the Hulk so much that
the Defenders initially attacked Hawkeye
thinking he was a villain threatening
the Hulk then when Hawkeye took over the
Thunderbolts he needed a way to boost
team morale once again he targeted the
Hulk just because he thought it would
help their image four years later in
Avengers number 74 Hawkeye decided the
best way to get his spot back in the
Avengers was to draw blood from one of
its founding members after Banner proved
that he could calm down She-Hulk by
talking to her Hawkeye went ahead and
shot Banner anyway to force him to Hulk
out even though he had a good reason to
shoot Banner in Civil War too one thing
is undeniable Hawkeye is a real jerk
what do you want
I wanted pickles
[Music]
for more than a decade the Tesseract has
been a crucial force behind the actions
and motivations of many of the Marvel
Cinematic universes major Players let's
take a look at some of the Lesser known
or little remembered facts about the
origins powers and timeline of the story
thread which has bound the Marvel movies
together
the Tesseract traces its Origins as far
back as time itself in the MCU the Big
Bang brought about six Primal Elemental
singularities time reality soul mind
power and space
one down
[Music]
five to go
the essence of the universe itself was
forged by mysterious Cosmic beings into
the Infinity Stones the space Stone came
into the possession of several ancient
civilizations including the celestials
at some point its power was harnessed by
a crystalline Cube casing the Tesseract
the origin of the cube has yet to be
revealed but its purpose was to tame the
raw power of the space Stone making it
more easily controllable at some point
Odin the ruler of Asgard came into
possession of the Tesseract and housed
it in his own vault as the crown jewel
of his collection of some of the most
powerful Cosmic weapons and artifacts in
the universe Odin captured and stored in
his heavily guarded Vault any weapon or
Relic he thought could possibly bring
about end times also known as Ragnarok
and the Tesseract to definitely fit that
bill
in the First Avenger Captain America
fights the Hydra super soldier Red Skull
aboard the Airship Valkyrie during the
film's climactic battle as the valkyrie
speeds towards New York City armed with
nuclear warheads The Red Skull attempts
to turn the tables on Cup by
bare-handing the Tesseract but it
doesn't exactly go well for him a portal
opens blasting Red Skull out of the ship
and carrying him after Parts Unknown
while the Tesseract Burns through the
hull of The Valkyrie and descends into
the depths of the ocean poor Steve
Rogers isn't far behind as the entire
Airship plunges into the icy water where
Captain America would remain Frozen for
the next 70 years is there anything you
can tell us about the Tesseract that we
ought to know now
should have left it in the ocean it was
nearly a decade before Red Skull
appeared in another MCU movie and his
Infinity War Cameo the character is
portrayed by Ross Marquand of The
Walking Dead Fame replacing the first
Avengers Hugo weaving drawing the film
it's revealed that the space Stone
transported Red Skull to vormir and
somehow imprisoned him there The Red
Skull explains that his quest to control
an infinity stone LED it to reject him
he's now intrinsically linked to the
Soul Stone as its Guardian but is never
able to possess it
sometime after Cap's fateful battle with
a red skull a deep sea Expedition led by
Howard Stark uncovered the Tesseract and
the cold Waters of the Arctic Ocean
while searching for the body of Steve
Rogers the brilliant inventor had been
instrumental in creating the scientific
process that transformed rudgers from a
scrawny weakling into a super soldier
while in possession of the Tesseract
Stark researched and studied its nature
at tesseract's official first on-screen
appearance comes in a stinger following
2011's store but the mcu's first
Tesseract reference is actually an Iron
Man 2. drawing a scene in which Howard's
son Tony is flipping through his
father's notebook the audience is able
to catch a glimpse of a drawing of the
tesseract
Project Pegasus was formed in the 1980s
as a joint operation between the United
States Air Force and NASA once the
Tesseract came into possession of the
U.S government the project had been
mentioned in other MCU films but Captain
Marvel was the first to shed more light
on the top secret undertaking Marvel a
crazy scientist posing as human doctor
Wendy Lawson on Earth is able to obtain
access to the Tesseract and attempts to
harness its power to produce a light
speed engine when a test fighter flown
by Carol Danvers and Lawson a shot down
by Cree StarForce Danver destroys a
powerful engine and then the process
absorbs the cosmic power of the space
Stone
and Captain Marvel Carol Danvers gains
full control of her powers and memories
in 1995. six years after her crash and
subsequent abduction by the cray she's
then able to thwart her pursuers and
uncover the Tesseract in the hidden
space station and Earth's near orbit
once recovered the Tesseract is kept
safe by Marvel's beloved pet cat Goose
of course goose is actually a cat-shaped
flirkin who stores the artifact in a
pocket dimension in her stomach
flirtkins just so happened to resemble
Earthly felines in many ways except for
the many toothy tentacles they can
release from their mouth that tentacles
enable the deceptively deadly flirkin to
devour large prey or objects to teleport
or store in stomach lining pocket
Dimensions later Goose Hawks up the
Tessa ragged onto Nick Fury's desk and
the Project Pegasus has revived to
further study the object it is soon
relocated to a shield facility in the
Mojave Desert to unlock its full
capabilities
the Tesla act has appeared in at least
10 Marvel Cinematic Universe films
that's the same number as Iron Man and
one more than everybody's favorite boy
scouts Captain America following the
wild success of Joss whedon's The
Avengers Marvel began to plot its
storytelling much more carefully than it
had before with this recollaboration
Marvel decided to make the Infinity
Stones the central story elements of
phases one through three as a result the
Tesseract was retconned to contain the
space Stone this pivot towards the
Infinity Stones as a binding agent of
the MCU will go down in Hollywood
history as one of the greatest
production moves of all time and with a
storyline more than 10 years in the
making finally coming to a close with
endgame it may indeed prove to be the
end of an era
with the Stellar success of the Iron Man
film franchise it's easy to forget that
the Golden Avenger wasn't always the
major player in the Marvel universe that
he is now the characters never exactly
been a c-lister but until Robert Downey
Jr infused the role with his
irresistible humor and Charisma you
couldn't exactly call him an a-lister
either because so much of the
superhero's popularity is based on the
films it's easy to forget how much the
source material differs from what you've
seen on the big screen so as a little
reminder here's the Untold Truth of Iron
Man
a different setting the opening scene of
2008's Iron Man is set in Afghanistan
where Tony Stark is showcasing his
weapons technology but most Americans
probably didn't even know the name
Afghanistan in 1963. instead Tony
Stark's origin in Tales of suspense
number 39 was set in a more recognizable
Locale to readers of that time Vietnam
according to Stan Lee his goals for the
story of Tony Stark made Vietnam A
fitting setting Lee knew exactly who the
Marvel readership was and he wanted to
create a character that challenged both
himself and his readers I'm gonna come
up with a character who represents
everything everybody hates and I'm going
to shove it down their throat
a boy and his dog if you only know Iron
Man from the movies you may be surprised
to learn that for the majority of his
existence Stark kept his super heroic
identity a secret to the rest of the
world Iron Man was actually Tony Stark's
bodyguard a nameless Good Samaritan
keeping the super rich Stark safe Iron
Man didn't reveal his true identity
until 2002's Iron Man number 400 when he
donned his armor in public without any
attempt to hide despite what you might
think it wasn't because of a villain's
blackmail or anything he just did it to
save a dog in this story Stark notices a
dog about to get hit by a bank robber's
car and leaps Into The Fray at the cost
of his secret identity now that's a
lucky Pooch truth is
I am Iron Man
you're fired for a CEO and billionaire
Tony Stark isn't great at keeping jobs
in 2004's Iron Man number 78 Tony Stark
was confirmed as the United States
Secretary of Defense his appointment was
short-lived however as part of the
Avengers disassembled event which
featured the Scarlet Witch using her
powers to destroy the team Stark found
himself magically drunk at the podium of
the U.N the drunk Stark became quickly
enraged and threatened a visiting
politician even for politics threatening
visiting dignitaries with laser blasts
was just a step too far and he soon lost
the cabinet position
seems fair but that wouldn't be his last
high-profile appointment in 2007 at the
end of Civil War number seven Stark was
named director of Shield unfortunately
he would lose that position by 2009
following secret Invasion making matters
worse he got replaced by Norman Osborne
the Green Goblin how embarrassing how
would you feel about getting replaced by
this guy
you know how much I sacrificed yeesh
fighting Hawkeye Iron Man is a founding
member of The Avengers acts as their
main source of finances and as the
supplier of all the stuff they tend to
break
foreign
he also has a knack for bringing in
other long-serving Avengers like the
arching Avenger Hawkeye Clint Barton
first found his way into the Marvel
Universe in 1964's Tales of suspense
number 57 enamored by the seductive
Black Widow herself a Villain at the
time Hawkeye fought Iron Man to help her
steal Stark's technology a year later in
Avengers number 16 Hawkeye became a hero
as part of the new roster of Avengers
along with Captain America and two other
former villains Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch but just because Hawkeye
was on the side of the Angels doesn't
mean that he wouldn't fight Iron Man
again Hawkeye joined the ranks of
another super team The Defenders right
before 1973's Avengers Defenders war
broke out when the two teams squared off
against each other it was Hawkeye and
Iron Man Who battled in 1973's Defenders
number nine this can't seem to miss
yeah first time for everything made you
look
a true Hulkbuster Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner might be science Bros in the MCU
but the two have gone Head to Head more
times than most friends Iron Man has
even managed to get the upper hand on a
couple occasions Iron Man's first and
most memorable victory over the Hulk
occurred in 1980s Iron Man number 132 in
the issue Iron Man put 100 of his
Armor's energy into a single punch and
with it he was able to KO the green
Goliath Stark rendered the Hulk
unconscious again in 2009's Mighty
Avengers number 22 by blasting the Hulk
with an exploding rocket booster
ironically as successful as the
Hulkbuster suit was in Avengers Age of
Ultron Iron Man has never been able to
defeat the Hulk while wearing the
Hulkbuster suit in the comics every Iron
Man Hulk fight involving the Hulkbuster
armor has ended in a canceled fight or
with the Hulk having busted the Buster
oh God
I'm sorry
the thorbuster armor
you hear a lot about Tony Stark's
Hulkbuster armor but the Hulk isn't the
only fellow Avenger that Iron Man
developed a specific armor to counter in
Marvel's 2003 three-part mini event
standoff Doctor Doom manipulated
international events to set Iron Man
Thor and Captain America against each
other not knowing how else he could even
stand a chance Stark created his
thorbuster suit powered by an Asgardian
Crystal that Thor had previously given
Stark as a gift the thorbuster rig
looked like a marriage between Tony's
classic red and gold suit and the
destroyer's armor But ultimately it
wasn't enough Thor destroyed the suit's
reactor and Tony ejected from the armor
the only thing that seems to get busted
when Tony pulls out a blank Buster suit
in the comics seems to be the suit
itself
foreign
there's never been another superhero
movie as epic as Avengers Infinity War
so it's time to look into everything
that went into crafting this Blockbuster
from the sheer scale of the star-studded
production to the improvised line or two
and stay tuned to find out which one of
your favorite Marvel heroes survived the
snap off screen the road to war
according to writers Christopher Marcus
and Stephen mcfeely work on the infinity
War script started around January 2016.
the story went through several
iterations before arriving at what we
saw including versions written well
before Thor Ragnarok and black panther
were completed that means a lot of
changes had to be made to Infinity war
from smaller missions to major
structural shifts Howard the Duck
originally made a brief reappearance
Thor banted a little more with the
Guardians of the Galaxy extra backstory
for the black order was included and we
even almost saw a destructive sequence
on Xander in which which Thanos claims
the Power Stone but perhaps most
intriguing of these changes involved
Steve Rogers whose role in the Final Cut
was already pretty limited Marcus and
mcfeely noted on Infinity War's
commentary that in one version of the
film cap didn't show up until the moment
he saves vision from corvus glaive in
wakanda well into the Final Act and then
after he read the draft and we did
conclude what we're all insane an Epic
Production in Infinity War's story spans
multiple planets and several continents
on earth features dozens of speaking
roles and a range of massive set pieces
which takes us from Edinburgh to wakanda
to Titan it stands to reason that the
production would be nothing short of
massive 2 and the numbers don't
disappoint consider that many of the
crew who worked on site had to be paid
fed and even housed and you'll get a
good idea of how big this film really
was according to co-director Joe Russo
in the featurette beyond the Battle of
wakanda over 6 000 people worked on the
film at one point or another all
collaborating to create over 3 000 shots
of those shots 2 900 required some form
of visual effects in post-production
which meant that a portion of the
infinity War effects team had to add
something to just about every second of
the film
influences obviously the comics
themselves had a major influence on the
plot of infinity warm but they weren't
alone directors Joe and Anthony Russo
are of course huge fans of Cinema and a
number of different films are referenced
throughout Infinity war on the film's
commentary track the moment in which
ebony Moore is burned while attempting
to steal the time stone is a nod to
Steven Spielberg's Raiders of the Lost
Ark
a later scene in which more torches
strange with needles is a reference to
Marathon Man while during interviews
around the film's release the russos
also highlighted a number of crime films
as influencers on Infinity War's
highest-like elements including out of
sight and two days in the valley room
for improvisation as massive as it is
infinity War required incredible amounts
of planning and structuring in order to
properly execute the script on screen
despite that however the filmmakers
still found room for a little
improvisation along the way for the
record this was my plan
for Mr Pratt in beyond the battle
wakanda the filmmakers note that the
Black Panther cast were performing the
wakandan war chants off-camera as a way
to warm themselves up for the action the
russos heard the chance and decided to
incorporate them into the film not all
of the new additions came from the cast
though on the commentary track the
filmmakers noted that rocket referring
to the outriders as Space Dogs came from
one viewer who called the creatures that
name during a focus group discussion
after an early test screening they
thought it was funny and added it to
Bradley Cooper's dialogue for his rocket
recording sessions
the living and the dead Infinity war
ends with one of the most devastating
gut punches in cinematic history a
montage spanning two planets showing us
the depths of numerous Marvel favorites
including Spider-Man Star-Lord Scarlet
Witch Black Panther and eventually even
Nick Fury
oh no
well
it feels like a huge loss but this is
only a tiny portion of the devastation
Thanos inflicted with his snap remember
we're talking about half of all life in
the universe here which means half of
anyone you've ever seen loved or hated
in an MCU film or series naturally the
filmmakers also made sure to keep track
of which characters survived and which
disintegrated off-screen on the survived
side you've got Howard the dark
Spider-Man's Aunt May and shuri and
Nakia from wakanda on the snapped side
there's the Incredible Hulk co-star
Betty Ross the Asgardian lady Sif and as
we later learned thanks to Ant-Man and
the WASP Hank Pym and hope and Janet Van
Dyne of course it is a safe bet that
none of them will be gone for too long
[Music]
Avengers Infinity War features more
Super characters than you can shake a
cosmically powered stick at most of them
you know and many of them have had their
own movies already even the Guardians of
the Galaxy crew is pretty familiar at
this point but some of the supporting
characters remain a little obscure for
instance what's the deal with nebula the
bald blue skinned cyborg played by Karen
Gillen how is her comics Incarnation
different from her character in the MCU
let's explore
thanos's granddaughter when nebula first
appeared in Avengers number 257 Thanos
wasn't even around he'd been turned to
stone years earlier and although he
wasn't technically dead he was just as
out of the picture one of the first
actions nebula took in those Comics was
to claim thanos's former headquarters
the sanctuary 2 for her own when Star
Fox thanos's brother claimed it as his
familial right nebula made the claim
that would come to Define her the space
station was rightfully hers because
Thanos was her grandfather
old look in her early appearances nebula
looked very different from the bald
cyborg she would eventually become she
was a fully organic humanoid alien with
gauntlets that enabled her to fire
destructive beams from her wrists she
had long bluish black hair that rose up
in big curls on the sides in one of
those hairstyles that's only possible in
comics nebula belongs to a race called
the luffamoids there are only a few of
them left in the Galaxy because Galactus
ate the planet of luffum and only those
luffamoids who are off Planet survived
other luffamoids like zor a villain who
first appeared in Nova number one were
desperate to find a new Homeworld for
their people nebula never seemed
interested in that being a space pirate
and the leader of a fleet of mercenaries
seemed to be her truest calling
no love from Grandpa whether nebula was
being honest about her relation to
Thanos was never particularly relevant
as long as he wasn't actually around
being a pirate and mercenary gave her
plenty to do in the universe hopping
Marvel Comics of the 1980s of course as
all classic villains eventually will
Thanos returned to life resurrected by
death herself in Silver Surfer number 38
he met the woman who claimed to be his
granddaughter he was not impressed and
claimed never to have fathered children
it was probably meant to be the truth at
the time but became a lie in light of
later stories because Comics are very
complicated declaring nebula's lies
unforgivable Thanos set her on fire with
beams from his eyes he meant to kill her
but crew members on the sanctuary 2
saved her life in a manner of speaking
when Thanos rediscovered nebula after
their first meeting she had been burned
beyond recognition profoundly brain
damaged and about to expire for Real by
this time Thanos had assembled the
infinity gems Into The Infinity Gauntlet
giving himself vast and god-like Powers
he used those powers to stop nebula from
croaking without actually healing her
she existed as a shambling nearly
mindless charred zombie of a creature
thanos's downfall
a confrontation with the cosmic being
known as eternity led to Thanos leaving
his body unattended while his
Consciousness dealt with larger Cosmic
matters this gave nebula who had been
repeatedly described as nearly mindless
the opportunity to grab The Infinity
Gauntlet off his hand and claim its
power for herself immediately restoring
her body and mind in the process she
didn't keep the gauntlet for long but
she enabled the defeat of Thanos and was
restored from her zombie-like state in
the process
bald is beautiful
after the events of The Infinity
Gauntlet nebulous physical form was
restored but her brain was still damaged
her longtime first mate giatar freed her
from imprisonment and took her to a
rogue space surgeon who promised to
restore her faculties when the fully
restored nebula was finally unveiled and
silver server number 72 she'd become a
bald cyborg who should look very
familiar to Marvel Cinematic Universe
fans finally back to her mental and
physical peak and even Beyond it thanks
to her cybernetic implants nebula
returned to the life of a space pirate
amazing Graces in Annihilation Ronin one
of the miniseries that was part of
Marvel's longer 2006 Annihilation event
nebula was reintroduced as a member of a
team of interstellar women warriors
known as The Graces the leader of The
Graces turned out to be a woman with an
even stronger connection to Thanos than
nebula herself ever had Gamora whereas
nebula only ever claimed to be the
granddaughter of Thanos a claim never
proven Gamora was actually raised by him
when Nicole Perlman and James Gunn were
writing Guardians of the Galaxy for the
screen and figuring out how to translate
all the complex mythology around Thanos
to the Cinematic Universe a story
emerged that was simpler and more
powerful than anything nebula and Gamora
had dealt with in the comics a story
about sisters
MCU update the nebula of the Guardians
of the Galaxy movies is like Gamora an
adopted daughter of Thanos unlike the
fully organic Gamora nebula has been
enhanced with extremely visible
cybernetics leaving her a mix of woman
and machine who suffers doubts about her
own selfhood her self-doubt combined
with her close relationship with Gamora
enables nebula to turn against Thanos
and become a sympathetic character and a
grudging Ally to the heroes she refuses
to join the Guardians of the Galaxy but
by the end of their second movie she's
no longer the group's enemy in fact her
new stated mission is to destroy Thanos
herself
I will help them by killing Thanos
setting up her appearances in Avengers
Infinity war and its as yet Untitled
sequel
just because Peter Parker's Aunt May is
getting on a bit doesn't mean she's
boring in fact there's much more to May
than just a mean batch of wheat cakes
from her humble beginnings to her big
screen debut and everything in between
here's the untold story of Marvel's most
iconic golden oldie
officially Mae and Ben Parker made their
canonical debut alongside Spider-Man an
Amazing Fantasy number 15. but
Spider-Man's origin story wasn't the
first time that the characters had
graced the pages of a Marvel comic a
couple of months before Spider-Man's big
entrance Stan Lee and Steve ditko
published a short story called goodbye
to Linda Brown in Strange Tales number
97 which featured early versions of both
appears relatives goodbye to Linda Brown
is only a few pages long and doesn't
leave much room for character
development but both Ben and may show
glimmers of their future selves for one
they look very similar to their Amazing
Fantasy counterparts especially May for
some reason the colorists decided to
give Ben a gray mustache although ditko
clearly didn't pencil one in in addition
both characters spend most of their time
fretting over a teenager with secret
superpowers which is pretty much all
Aunt May did for the first 50 issues or
so of The Amazing Spider-Man luckily
things did get a little more interesting
after that
most Vans probably saw ant May in the
flesh for the first time in Sam raimi's
2002 Spider-Man movie in which Peter
Parker's daughter and aunt was played by
emmy-winning actress Rosemary Harris but
Harris wasn't actually the first person
to bring May to life in a live action
project that honor goes to Jeff Donald
and so were clear Jean-Marie Donald went
by her nickname Jeff so that explains
that anyway she portrayed Aunt May in a
90-minute TV movie that served as the
backdoor pilot for the 1977 Spider-Man
television series Donald only played
Aunt May in the Spider-Man Pilots for
May's later appearances the role was
assumed by a number of different
actresses including reoccurring Dennis
the Menace star Irene tedro and of
course many actresses tackled the role
of Aunt May in the world of Animation
before Harris immortalized her on the
big screen June Foray voiced May and
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends in
which Spidey and Company operated out of
May's Queen's based Abode but you
probably know foray better as the
original voices of both Rocky the flying
squirrel and his arch nemesis Natasha
fatal in terms of early Spider-Man
stories you won't find much that's more
iconic Than The Amazing Spider-Man
number 33 this comic titled the Final
Chapter isn't actually co-creator Steve
ditko's final pass at Spider-Man but it
does feel like an end of an era and it
puts Aunt May front and center of the
story as the issue opens Aunt May lies
at a hospital bed dying from a
transfusion a Peter Parker's radioactive
blood the only cure is an isotope known
as ISO 36 which is contained in an
underwater lab controlled by
Spider-Man's arch nemesis Dr Octopus the
two fight and destroy the lab and as it
fills with water Spider-Man is pinned
underneath multiple tons of Fallen steel
with no hope of escape the following
four pages are arguably ditko's finest
work in any Spider-Man comic at least
that's what Stan Lee thinks Lee later
said it was one of my all-time favorite
stories it was such a thrill even to me
and I was the writer of the story when I
saw that I almost shouted in Triumph
Steve did a wonderful job and who does
Peter have to thank for his big moment
well did go of course but also Aunt May
as the water rises Spider-Man thinks
about his beloved aunt and how he's
failed her in the past namely by letting
an anonymous robber get away leaving him
free to kill her husband Ben using May's
strength and resilience as motivation
Peter lifts the steel beams above his
head and escapes he delivers the isotope
to the hospital in the nick of time and
with May cured puts the Specter of Uncle
Ben's death behind him once and for all
the scene is so iconic that it plays out
on the big screen too and Spider-Man
homecoming The Amazing Spider-Man number
121 in which the Green Goblin kills
Peter Parker's girlfriend Gwen Stacy is
arguably one of the most important and
notorious superhero comics ever
published but it almost played out very
very differently originally Gwen Stacy
was going to make it to the end of the
issue alive and well while Aunt May was
to meet her demise at the Goblin's hands
instead that Revelation comes from none
other than long time Spider-Man artist
John romita Senior who co-plotted the
issue with writer Jerry Conway while
talking to CBR romita confessed that he
and not Conway are artist Gil Kane was
Gwen Stacy's real murderer the original
plan was to sacrifice Aunt May to the
Green Goblin but romita pushed back on
the idea claiming that it would actually
make The Amazing Spider-Man less
dramatic Romina explained it'll lose one
of Peter Parker's Hang-Ups he won't have
to worry about Aunt May anymore he won't
be treated like a child anymore if we
want to make any kind of stir in the
monthly line we have to kill somebody
important and so ramidia explained the
victim had to be one of the stories
leading female figures from there Gwen
Stacy became the obvious choice at the
time Mary Jane was what romita called an
airhead comedy character but Gwen Stacy
was the love of Peter Parker's life in
order to ring the maximum amount of
emotional turmoil out of the story Gwen
had to go and the rest of course is
history
Aunt May's abilities aren't limited to
Simply fretting about the well-being of
superheroes though in fact she's also a
superhero herself sort of and what if
number 23 a backup feature called what
if Aunt May instead of her nephew Peter
had been bitten by that radioactive
spider tells the story about it's kind
of obvious isn't it an Amazing Fantasy
number 15. Peter attends a scientific
demonstration where he crosses paths
with the Fateful radioactive spider in
what if number 23 he leaves his bagged
lunch at home and Aunt May rushes to the
Science Institute to deliver it while
she's there the spider bites May on the
hand and her spider powers kick in on
the walk home May quickly sews herself a
costume and creates a unique version of
Spider-Man's web fluid out of some over
yeast dough before long she's taken to
the streets as Spider-Man juggling her
crime-fighting career with her familial
responsibilities and while what if
stories aren't canonical writer Christos
Gage and artist Dave Williams made
Spider-Man a reality and Spider-Man team
up number three part of Dan Slaughter
Olivier koipel's Dimension hopping epic
spider-verse in the comic a team of
Spider-Man including the Peter Parker we
know and love travel to earth 3123 to
rescue Spider-Man from Karn an
interdimensional Hunter with a mad
hatred for everything spider related the
team is successful but the battle leads
to a dramatic development in
Spider-Man's story she finally reveals
her secret identity to her husband and
nephew whose lives are changed forever
the list of people who have stopped
Galactus Marvel Comics gargantuan
Devourer of Worlds is pretty short the
Fantastic Four have done it of course so
if Thanos the Silver Surfer and the
beyonder and Aunt May wait what this
tale took place in Marvel team up number
137 which was part of Marvel's assistant
editor's month an event during which
some of Marvel's top creators were given
free reign to tell the wildest and
silliest stories they could imagine in
the comic Spider-Man and the Fantastic
Four head off to San Diego to thwart an
unnamed disaster leaving Reid Richards
and Sue Storm's super powered son
Franklin in ant May's care unfortunately
just after the real heroes leave town
Galactus arrives in search of a new
Herald and he's got his sights set on
Franklin one ill-aimed energy blast
later and Aunt May is transformed into
the golden oldie a glowing super heroine
infused with the power of cosmic I
believe there's a hero in all of us
that keeps us honest
gives us strength thanks to Galactus all
of Aunt May's health problems her
arthritis or vitamin deficiencies her
Bingo addiction are gone but there's a
catch Galactus is hungry and it's up to
his Herald to keep him fed at Franklin's
prompting May beats Galactus a Twinkie
he loves it and demands more using her
Newfound Powers May scours first Earth
then the entire galaxy for more of the
spongy cream-filled snack cakes on her
travels she meets an alien that looks
suspiciously like the Pillsbury Doughboy
who just happens to make planets that
resemble Hostess products at May's
suggestion Galactus takes the alien on
as his new Herald and frees May from her
responsibilities when she returns home
Franklin absorbs all of May's Cosmic
powers and everything goes back to
normal right before writer Michael
Carlin reveals that the whole Adventure
was just a bad dream or was it
Peter Parker will always be the main man
in May Parker's life but with such a
busy day-to-day life May's nephew
doesn't always have time for his
beleaguered Aunt thankfully despite her
age May is incredibly popular with the
fellas and has accumulated quite a
collection of dudes to keep her company
while Peter's away there was Ben Parker
of course who met his tragic demise in
Amazing Fantasy number 15. but before
Ben and may got hitched she almost
married a criminal named Johnny Jerome
who tried to win her heart with money
and who returned to plague her in the
spectacular Spider-Man Annual number
four in The Amazing Spider-Man number 54
Dr Octopus rents May's spare room and
wins her over with his charms and in The
Amazing Spider-Man number 131 he
actually tries to marry her in order to
steal her inheritance although
Hammerhead and Spider-Man interrupt the
wedding before it becomes official
real homie oh great it's live throughout
the 80s May dated Nathan lubensky a
reformed gambling addict who asked me to
marry him before he relapsed fell afoul
of the vulture and died an Amazing
Spider-Man number 336 in the early 90s
she enjoyed a brief fling with a
fantastic Four's longtime mailman Willie
Lumpkin after Peter Parker and Aunt May
move to Stark Tower in the build-up to
Civil War May and Tony Stark's Butler
Jarvis shared a mutual attraction
finally Mae dated and married Jay Jonah
Jameson's Father John Jameson senior and
stayed with him until he died of a rare
hereditary disease in The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 4 number 19. Aunt May
actress Rosemary Harris was 75 in 2002
when Sam raimi's Spider-Man hit theaters
when she appeared as May and The Amazing
Spider-Man Sally Field was 66. by
contrast Marissa Tomei who plays May in
the modern MCU was only 50 when she
first starred as Peter Parker's favorite
aunt that's significantly younger than
May is usually portrayed in Civil War
Tony Stark even jokes about it who else
knows anybody
nobody
not even your unusually attractive aunt
but don't blame tomay while appearing on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert Tomei
revealed that she actually petitioned
Marvel to make May into a senior citizen
just like in the comics but the studio
declined I actually made a case to go
with to age me up but no thank you no
besides as civil war co-writer Stephen
mcfeely has explained a younger Aunt May
makes perfect sense given that Tom
Holland's Peter Parker is still in high
school mcfeely told the Los Angeles
Times that's partly why his aunt isn't
80 years old if she's the sister of his
dead mother why does she have to be two
generations ahead in other words the
mcu's Aunt May isn't too young at all in
the comics she's actually way too old
an intriguing character from Marvel
Comics catalog will be getting his very
first Solo movie vehicle in 2021 Shang
Chi Master of Kung Fu who is Shang Chi
and how did he come to be the master of
kung fu and what is his place within the
world of Marvel Comics we're here to
break down the details for you you may
be aware that in the early 1970s
Everybody Was Kung Fu Fighting or at
least they wanted to be this was largely
thanks to Bruce Lee who had been exposed
to American audiences via the television
series The Green Hornet and with
starring roles in films including Game
of Death and the posthumously released
Enter the Dragon which kicked open the
door for future Superstars like Jackie
Chan the TV series Kung Fu which starred
actor David Carradine is said to have
originally been developed for Bruce Lee
Marvel hoped to adapt the series to cash
in on the martial arts craze but the
house of ideas was unable to obtain the
rights as quickly as you can
snatch the pebble from my head
[Applause]
so then Marvel publisher Stan Lee turned
to creators Steve ingleheart and Jim
Starlin to come up with an original Kung
Fu based property the character they
created would go on to become a Marvel
Mainstay in the late 80s long before
Marvel came to dominate the box office
Stanley attempted to get a Shang Chi
movie off the ground starring Brandon
Lee Bruce's son it never materialized
not everyone was convinced that Master
of Kung Fu would be an instant hit so
Marvel introduced the character in a
dead-end book with the clunky title of
special Marvel Edition which had up to
that point published 14 issues of
reprints of older Marvel stories much
like Spider-Man who first appeared in
Amazing Fantasy number 15 Shang Chi
debuted in the pages of special Marvel
Edition number 15 published in December
1973. the public quickly took notice it
only took two issues for the book's
former title to be dropped it was
renamed hands of Shang Chi Master of
Kung Fu for the remainder of its run
which lasted until 1983. Shang Chi
enjoyed a respectable level of
popularity throughout the 70s making
guest appearances in several of Marvel's
Flagship books and interacting with some
of its most high profile characters
despite the success it was as they say a
different time and some elements of the
character's backstory were more than a
little questionable Chief among these
problems was Shang Chi's lineage in his
very first appearance he was presented
as the son of the evil Fu Manchu and
overtly racist super villain who had
appeared in Pulp novels and movies
throughout the 20th century the
character was among the most popular of
the so-called yellow Peril villains
which spawned a number of devious
heartless Asian evildoers such as Flash
Gordon arch villain Ming the merciless
and the Batman villain Roz al Ghul
Marvel obtained the rights from Fu
manchu's Creator British novelist sex
Roamer and while their characterization
was a touch more dignified many Asian
readers nevertheless found the character
to represent a demonization of their
culture in his original origin Shang Chi
was raised by his father to be the
Ultimate Assassin but quickly came to
reject Fu manchu's evil ways over the
years the two would Clash repeatedly in
later years the identity of the hero's
father would be retconned to actually be
the immortal sorcerer Zhang Zhu who for
decades had simply been using Fu Manchu
as an alias but this was largely due to
the the rights reverting back to romer's
estate rather than a desire to rehab the
character like many of Marvel's heroes
Shang Chi technically doesn't have any
superpowers he was molded by his father
into the Ultimate Weapon a master
practitioner of all forms of Chinese
martial arts not only does this mean
that he's an absurdly skilled fighter it
also means that he has a level of
control over his body that few
characters in the Marvel Universe can
match he's able to regulate a number of
supposedly involuntary bodily functions
for example he can reduce the function
of his nerves to the extent that he's
practically impervious to pain and he
can even slow down the rate at which he
bleeds he also has a master's knowledge
of pressure points enabling him to take
down opponents with a single strike and
is known to unleash a bone rattling
flying kick Which packs an unbelievable
amount of force behind it like Captain
America he's said to represent the peak
of human strength power and Agility he
does however boast one skill specific to
only the most skilled of martial artists
one that raises his abilities to a level
slightly Beyond those of fellow
non-powered Heroes Shang Chi has the
ability to focus his Qi the spiritual
energy or life force inherent to all
living things in Real World Martial Arts
this practice is used mainly in
meditation and as a way of controlling
one's fear and anger and the Marvel
Universe the ability can be honed into a
weapon and shangshi uses it to augment
his skills to devastating effect he can
temporarily boost his strength and
endurance Beyond even Peak human levels
Dodge or deflect bullets and control his
body's reaction to poison or drugs
because of these abilities and his utter
Mastery of an array of deadly fighting
styles shangshi is often considered to
be the greatest unarmed combatant in the
entire Marvel Universe he was deemed by
no less an authority than black panther
to be an even more formidable fighter
than the super-powered Iron Fist his
Mastery over his Chi has even received a
technological boost at times he uses a
special pair of nunchucks designed by
Tony Stark which can accumulate and
disperse Shang Chi's spiritual energy
unleashing deadly concussive blasts
Shang Chi's interactions with other
Marvel heroes has been frequent but one
of his Wilder team-ups was with an
unlikely band of new york-based Heroes
it started with an investigation into
the bizarre Slaughter of an entire
faction of Brooklyn mafia members
Daredevil discovered it was the work of
eulik a rock troll hailing from asgard's
Underworld who had come to Earth in
search of a mystical horn Daredevil
Enlisted the aid of Shang Chi Black
Widow a cloakless dagger and The
Punisher to form the Marvel Knights and
deal with eulik and his minions
afterwards the rest of the group became
determined to bring the Punisher whose
methods they found to be unsavory to
Justice they were joined in this
dangerous Endeavor by Moon Knight but
the revamped group's efforts were
interrupted by cloak who was in the
psychological clutches of the demon
Nightmare and was on a misguided Rampage
to consume all evildoers after consuming
The Punisher Daredevil Black Widow and
Moon Knight cloak was halted by Doctor
Strange whom dagger had brought in to
assist before things got truly out of
hand by the end of the series The
Punisher was still punishing away Shang
Chi has occasionally been called upon to
train other heroes in hand-to-hand
combat including your friendly
neighborhood wall crawler during the
Revenge of the Spider Slayer story arc
Spider-Man realized that the villain
Alistair Smythe had found a way to imbue
his Spider Slayer robots with a version
of his Spider Sense he created a device
to disrupt the ability but was forced to
set it off manually deactivating his own
Spider Sense in the process this caused
some difficulty in the subsequent spider
Island event during which thousands of
Heroes villains and ordinary citizens
alike developed spider powers on the
recommendation of Madam Webb Spidey went
to Shang Chi for training he created a
completely new martial arts style
intended to complement Spider-Man's
Powers which he called The Way of the
spider Spider-Man became an even more
dangerous fighter than he already was
using his Newfound martial arts prowess
to take down opponents as powerful and
skilled as Spider-Woman and even Shang
Chi himself
Shang Chi has at times been imparted
with superhuman abilities during the
aforementioned spider Island event he
was one of the many temporarily granted
the same Powers as Spider-Man a scary
notion if ever there was one he used
these powers to help dispatch the threat
of the spider-powered super villains
running roughshod over New York City in
another incident Shang Chi was
dispatched with other Avengers to the
fictional island of madrapore to deal
with an ancient dragon which had been
awakened from its Slumber underneath the
island using Pym particles Shang Chi
enlarged himself to match the dragon's
godzilla-like stature and promptly
defeated it in combat in a more recent
incident shangshi volunteered to
investigate the city of Kobe Japan after
it was struck with the evolution
speeding origin Bomb by the Godlike
entity known as ex-nilio While others
had been absorbed by the Genesis matter
which was a byproduct of the bombing
shangshi was able to commune with it and
in the process gained the ability to
produce an unknown number of duplicates
of himself each one with the original's
memories and abilities it's unknown
whether he still possesses this power
back in 2006 when Marvel first announced
its intentions to start Marvel Studios
and produce a slate of films featuring
some of its lesser-known characters
virtually no one was thinking that the
Endeavor would result in the single
highest grossing film franchise of all
time
Avengers
assembled the rights to Marvel's most
famous properties namely Spider-Man and
the X-Men were held by Sony and fox
respectively both of which had created
successful film franchises Marvel seemed
to be coming late to the party with a
stable of characters that included in
the order they were announced Captain
America The Avengers Nick Fury black
panther Ant-Man Cloak and Dagger Dr
Strange Hawkeye power pack and Shang Chi
Marvel Studios would of course go on to
elevate many of these properties to
household name status although some took
considerably longer to develop than
others Ant-Man took a full nine years to
reach the big screen and the pre-teen
power pack have yet to get its time in
the spotlight but finally well over a
decade after the fact Shang Chi stands
poised to join the MCU thanks in part to
another solo vehicle which became one of
Marvel's biggest success stories and one
of the biggest films of 2018. black
panther astonished audiences crafted
mainly by African-American filmmakers
and featuring a hero who is the king of
the technologically advanced African
nation of Honda this never gets ordered
the film proved that big budget
Blockbusters created from a specific
cultural Viewpoint can resonate strongly
with General audiences and it even
outgrossed the Juggernaut that was
Avengers Infinity War at the domestic
box office taking a cue from this
success Marvel appears to have gone all
in on diversity and it's likely the
studios hope that Shang Chi and the
legend of the ten rings can strike a
similar chord in pop culture at large to
this end the production has been loaded
up with talented people of Asian descent
on both sides of the camera Japanese
irish-american Destin Daniel [ __ ] will
direct from a screenplay by
chinese-american scribe Dave Callahan
who is contributing to Warner Brothers
upcoming Wonder Woman 1984 as well as
Sony Pictures animations as yet Untitled
sequel to Spider-Man into the
spider-verse Chinese Canadian actor simu
Liu has landed the title role and the
suddenly ubiquitous rapper turned actor
Aquafina will appear Among The
Supporting Cast legendary Chinese actor
Tony Leong will Star as the Mandarin an
iconic villain who many fans feel was
previously given extremely short shrift
the title of shangshi's solo vehicle
quickly got the attention of Marvel fans
eluding as it does to a mysterious
terrorist organization that has lurked
in the shadows of the MCU since its
Inception the ten rings are the group
responsible for Tony Stark's kidnapping
in Iron Man they've been alluded to in
both of that film sequels as well as
Ant-Man they're led by none other than
the real Mandarin who famously wears a
ring on every finger in the comics this
is not the phony Trevor Slattery or his
Handler Aldrich Killian both of whom
falsely laid claim to the Mandarin name
but he's not here he's here but he's not
here he's in Shang Chi and the legend of
the ten Rings this group will finally
step out of the shadows and truly make
their presence felt the ten rings are
dedicated to nothing less than the
destabilization of the entire planet
sowing the kind of chaos which will lead
to the collapse of world governments and
create a power vacuum they've butted
heads with Iron Man Black Widow and Nick
Fury but they'll soon face the Master of
Kung Fu who never met a challenge that
he couldn't kick the absolute crap out
of
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite things are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]